Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: and sorry for the slight delay but we're
Caption: ready to go now
Caption: all right so our first talk for today is
Caption: ricky barnes
Caption: who will be speaking about escaping the
Caption: vortex or how i learned to stop
Caption: procrastinating and get things done
Caption: mostly
Caption: so a little bit about ricky ricky barnes
Caption: is a full stack developer contributing
Caption: to challenging the impossible at the
Caption: mindaroo foundation her colleagues know
Caption: her as a hard worker with an eye for
Caption: detail
Caption: from her first homework extension in
Caption: year three through two undergraduate
Caption: degrees and over 15 years of industry
Caption: experience ricky has honed to
Caption: procrastination abilities to a truly
Caption: expert level
Caption: despite several gratifying achievements
Caption: such as never handling in a single
Caption: assignment on time throughout her second
Caption: degree
Caption: ricky has embarked on a course
Caption: correction of avoiding distractions
Caption: prioritizing daily objectives and
Caption: claiming back her time for real goals
Caption: and priorities
Caption: all right thank you ricky
Caption: hi everyone as you heard i am a lifelong
Caption: procrastinator and about a year ago i
Caption: decided to get serious about trying to
Caption: be more effective because i'm not just
Caption: an accomplished procrastinator i'm also
Caption: very easily distracted and honestly
Caption: being an easily distracted
Caption: procrastinator
Caption: is very frustrating i end up cross with
Caption: myself a lot
Caption: and being a little bit like
Caption: why are you like this i say this to
Caption: myself all the time
Caption: i called my talk escaping the vortex
Caption: because vortex is a shorthand that one
Caption: of my friends and i have always used to
Caption: explain this behavior where you get
Caption: sucked into something and you can't seem
Caption: to stop yourself from doing it and
Caption: that's even if you've got something else
Caption: that you should be doing or even if
Caption: there's something else that you would
Caption: rather be doing
Caption: so
Caption: i'm assuming since you're all here you
Caption: know how it feels to get sucked into the
Caption: vortex right
Caption: so why do we get sucked into the vortex
Caption: there's a couple of reasons
Caption: i think it's because the way our brains
Caption: are wired makes us susceptible to both
Caption: both procrastination and distraction
Caption: and also because the things that are
Caption: meant to engage us specifically leverage
Caption: that in order to hook us in
Caption: i'm going to look at the reasons why we
Caption: procrastinate
Caption: and how understanding that can help us
Caption: overcome it
Caption: i'm going to give a couple of examples
Caption: of when i've procrastinated dissect the
Caption: reasons behind it and then show the
Caption: strategies that i use to get back on
Caption: with distraction we're going to discuss
Caption: a little bit of behavioral science but
Caption: not too much because it's complicated
Caption: and it's kind of a vortex in itself
Caption: and then we're going to look at the
Caption: practical steps that i took in order to
Caption: overcome distraction these steps are
Caption: aimed at both the external and the
Caption: internal triggers of distraction
Caption: and those triggers are things that
Caption: prompt us towards being distracted
Caption: strategies that i use to get back on
Caption: track show some stats that show how i
Caption: improved my performance at work if
Caption: you're wondering where this mostly comes
Caption: into it it's because i'm still finding
Caption: it pretty challenging to overcome
Caption: distraction and procrastination in my
Caption: personal life
Caption: i'm managing it a bit it's a bit better
Caption: than it was
Caption: it's a work in progress
Caption: so to get started let's look at
Caption: procrastination
Caption: i think most people are pretty familiar
Caption: with procrastination
Caption: is something you're supposed to be doing
Caption: often something pretty important
Caption: but for some reason you just can't seem
Caption: to get started on doing it
Caption: instead you're doing something that you
Caption: know for a fact isn't helpful
Caption: like watching tv or scrolling on social
Caption: media
Caption: or you're doing something that your
Caption: procrastination is sneakily trying to
Caption: pretend is helpful like
Caption: just clearing my desk so i can focus
Caption: better
Caption: so i think when we think about
Caption: procrastination the
Caption: instinct is to kind of write it off as
Caption: laziness or lack of motivation
Caption: sorry excuse me
Caption: um so the fix is easy if you are a
Caption: better person with better self-control
Caption: you wouldn't procrastinate so much
Caption: right now this is obviously ridiculous
Caption: and yet it is the most common way that
Caption: people try and overcome procrastination
Caption: you do some you procrastinate you feel
Caption: guilty about it you beat yourself up
Caption: about it
Caption: and then
Caption: you promise yourself you're going to do
Caption: better maybe you even do manage to do
Caption: better for a while
Caption: but
Caption: eventually you're going to end up back
Caption: at procrastination again
Caption: so why is this
Caption: i think it's because
Caption: better self-control doesn't address the
Caption: underlying reasons behind
Caption: procrastination
Caption: so
Caption: it doesn't get to the root causes now
Caption: i'm going to show here a list of reasons
Caption: for procrastination and it's pretty
Caption: comprehensive although i think you can
Caption: probably think of some others
Caption: but
Caption: sorry i'm a little bit
Caption: overwhelmed feeling over
Caption: um
Caption: i think
Caption: if we look at this it seems a little bit
Caption: overwhelming in and of itself right this
Caption: is a very small font to be working with
Caption: but i think if we look into it a little
Caption: more closely we can see that these
Caption: root causes these reasons can be broken
Caption: down into
Caption: just five
Caption: root causes maybe can maybe it can't
Caption: yes it can
Caption: okay now i'm gonna leave out the
Caption: physical and or mental factors
Caption: they're obviously a massive problem for
Caption: a lot of people but it's really above my
Caption: pay grade to be discussing them the only
Caption: thing i can say is that if these things
Caption: are a big issue for you
Caption: then you should address them first
Caption: because otherwise any of the work you
Caption: try and do in any of these other areas
Caption: is going to be undermined
Caption: okay so
Caption: damn it i keep pressing the wrong button
Caption: right
Caption: so if we look at what's left i think we
Caption: can see that this can be boiled down
Caption: into just one thing
Caption: avoiding pain
Caption: it might be minor pain like my tax is
Caption: really boring or more significant pain
Caption: like
Caption: i'm really stressed i'm going to do a
Caption: bad job of my ddd talk and end up
Caption: looking like an idiot in front of a
Caption: bunch of people
Caption: news flash it's kind of happening guys
Caption: so
Caption: look
Caption: wherever it is whatever the reasons
Caption: where it leaves us is avoiding the pain
Caption: in the short term
Caption: but then that often leaves us with
Caption: greater pain in the longer term and
Caption: actually there's a lot of people who
Caption: work in this space that include that in
Caption: their definition of procrastination it's
Caption: not just that we're putting off an
Caption: important task is also the knowledge
Caption: that we're going to be worse off for
Caption: having delayed it we know this is what's
Caption: going to happen
Caption: and yet i do it all the time
Caption: and that brings us back to
Caption: why are you like this why am i like this
Caption: okay well i think if we look at a couple
Caption: of examples
Caption: let's start with tax like i was talking
Caption: about before it's really boring right
Caption: so
Caption: the first reason is task aversion it's
Caption: boring and it sucks and because i don't
Caption: want to do this boring task that sucks
Caption: throughout the year i leave it all to
Caption: the end
Caption: where it takes longer and is therefore
Caption: more boring
Caption: and because it takes longer i need
Caption: elevated levels of perseverance but i
Caption: don't have that because the task is
Caption: boring and it sucks
Caption: now that could explain everything right
Caption: it's boring it sucks no wonder i want to
Caption: procrastinate but actually if we dig a
Caption: little further into it there are a
Caption: couple of things around the future that
Caption: come into play
Caption: so
Caption: it doesn't take me long to do my tax
Caption: right it's maybe like an hour and a half
Caption: and the government is just going to give
Caption: me money
Caption: they're just going to give it to me
Caption: why wouldn't i just do it
Caption: well
Caption: the thing is by the time my accountant
Caption: files and the government processes it's
Caption: kind of a little bit far in the future
Caption: so there's a delayed outcome it's not
Caption: like there's a guy standing next to me
Caption: with a lot of cash going if you do this
Caption: for an hour you can have this
Caption: and it's not even that far in the future
Caption: but the reason it becomes important is
Caption: because there's a disconnect with my
Caption: future self
Caption: i'm like
Caption: i'm doing all this work so her in three
Caption: weeks time gets a cash present what am i
Caption: getting out of this
Caption: now what i'm getting out of it is
Caption: obviously the cash present because i'm
Caption: the same person
Caption: but in the moment it doesn't feel like
Caption: that
Caption: the last thing is that this is a bit of
Caption: an abstract goal i don't have anything
Caption: specifically that i'm saving for
Caption: there's nothing i've really earmarked
Caption: this money for
Caption: so
Caption: there's not really anything specific
Caption: that would make me
Caption: motivated to strive to do this
Caption: now if we look at another task oh sorry
Caption: gone a little bit far if we're going to
Caption: look at another task which is a
Caption: development task that i had to do at
Caption: work
Caption: so we had a bit of a collaborative
Caption: strategy meeting about what i would be
Caption: doing but it wasn't something i'd done
Caption: before so i didn't really know what i
Caption: was doing
Caption: so the first one as you've got a preview
Caption: of is indecisiveness
Caption: there were a couple of different paths i
Caption: could take because i hadn't done it
Caption: before i didn't know which one would be
Caption: the best one
Caption: i was also feeling a little bit
Caption: overwhelmed
Caption: because i hadn't done it before
Caption: i was a little bit out of my depth
Caption: then i had general anxiety specifically
Caption: around the deadline because
Caption: it was a hard deadline and i knew that i
Caption: had to meet it it was a hard deadline
Caption: that was a little bit tight actually so
Caption: the pressure was on
Caption: then there's fear of evaluation and this
Caption: one is because
Caption: my leader is this like
Caption: insane code whisperer genius person and
Caption: that's usually a really good thing but
Caption: it always adds an extra level of fear
Caption: about
Caption: how good my code is
Caption: then there's a bit of task aversion in
Caption: this one as well
Caption: and that's mainly because i could help
Caption: this by doing a little bit of research
Caption: but i really find going on to like stack
Caption: overflow
Caption: or
Caption: browsing through random repos usually a
Caption: bit tedious
Caption: so if we put all that together it's not
Caption: hard to see why i want to put this off
Caption: right if i don't even think about this
Caption: task i'm going to be saving myself a lot
Caption: of discomfort
Caption: but that's only in the short term in the
Caption: long term
Caption: i'm going to be adding fear of failure
Caption: to my list because
Caption: if i waste time
Caption: there's a real possibility that i'm
Caption: gonna miss the deadline
Caption: all right sorry
Caption: um so you can see my reasons for
Caption: procrastination with both of these
Caption: things were very different
Caption: okay
Caption: now we've discovered what my reasons for
Caption: doing this were
Caption: let's see what we can do to help me from
Caption: stop to stop me from procrastinating
Caption: this is again a comprehensive list with
Caption: quite small font
Caption: of some of the common things that people
Caption: suggest that you might use to overcome
Caption: procrastination
Caption: now
Caption: um
Caption: i think
Caption: this is probably a lot to take in but
Caption: the one i would suggest paying attention
Caption: to the most is this figuring out the
Caption: exact nature of your procrastination
Caption: problem which is what we just went
Caption: through there
Caption: i think this should always be the first
Caption: step
Caption: because the reasons that we procrasti
Caption: procrastinate as we just saw are always
Caption: very different and that means that you
Caption: need different tools to overcome it you
Caption: can't apply the same stuff in every
Caption: situation
Caption: okay
Caption: so
Caption: we return to my tax problem these are
Caption: all the reasons that i was
Caption: procrastinating
Caption: and we'll look at how i'm going to
Caption: overcome this one
Caption: so task aversion
Caption: i'm going to address by making a low bar
Caption: commitment
Caption: what i'm going to do in this case is to
Caption: say
Caption: work on this for five minutes and then
Caption: you can do 10 minutes of whatever you
Caption: want i'm going to work on it for 5
Caption: minutes again then i can do 10 minutes
Caption: of whatever i want now this is going to
Caption: work for me for a couple of reasons
Caption: because it's
Caption: extremely short-term
Caption: i'm going to get a reward almost
Caption: straight away
Caption: it's going to stop me from feeling
Caption: guilty about prioritizing my short-term
Caption: mood
Caption: because actually
Caption: now that i've said i can have those 10
Caption: minutes of reward those 10 minutes are
Caption: no longer procrastination they're
Caption: actually what i said i was going to do
Caption: in my plan
Caption: it's also going to get me started on the
Caption: task so i can stop feeling guilty that
Caption: i'm putting it off
Caption: i don't have to have that dread hanging
Caption: over me that oh god i really should do
Caption: it
Caption: this is also going to address my lack of
Caption: perseverance because i only have to do
Caption: it for five minutes
Caption: it's not really needing that much
Caption: self-control to keep going with it
Caption: the key thing with this is
Caption: obviously once you get started on a task
Caption: five minutes can slip away really
Caption: quickly and actually find out it's not
Caption: as bad as you thought it was so now that
Caption: i've got myself started i'm probably
Caption: going to be engrossed and when the five
Caption: minutes are up
Caption: i'm maybe not going to want to actually
Caption: stop i'm probably halfway through
Caption: something that i don't want to leave
Caption: unfinished
Caption: so i've got myself moving
Caption: so
Caption: my abstract goal i'm going to address by
Caption: attaching meaning to the task now
Caption: there's a couple of things that i can
Caption: attach meaning to here
Caption: firstly there's the reward which is
Caption: getting my return
Caption: secondly there's the negative outcome
Caption: of getting a fine from the ato which has
Caption: happened to me before
Caption: okay and i actually get fairly
Caption: frustrated with myself when i end up
Caption: with a stupid fine over nothing that was
Caption: completely avoidable so what i'm going
Caption: to do
Caption: is visualize the outcomes of me doing
Caption: this work or in that case not doing the
Caption: work i can remind myself that i'm going
Caption: to be really frustrated if i get a fine
Caption: and then i can also visualize that i'm
Caption: going to get this little return it's
Caption: going to be in my bank balance it's
Caption: going to be a great time
Caption: okay i'm also going to reward myself and
Caption: that's going to
Caption: help me with the delayed outcomes
Caption: problem it's not an immediate reward
Caption: like my 10 minutes what it's going to be
Caption: is something tangible
Caption: so i'm going to get my return from the
Caption: government
Caption: and then what i'm going to do with that
Caption: is actually
Caption: say i'm going to buy x with it
Caption: specifically something that i want right
Caption: and then i'm going to say to myself
Caption: you're not allowed to buy x
Caption: unless you do your tax return
Caption: so now this is my task
Caption: at work that i was procrastinating on
Caption: there's my little things including the
Caption: fear of failure that came in at the end
Caption: and i'm gonna address my indecisiveness
Caption: by sitting down with someone for five
Caption: minutes and having them act as my rubber
Caption: ducky i'm gonna have a little
Caption: conversation
Caption: i'm gonna be able to outline my thoughts
Caption: more clearly and i'm gonna clarify how
Caption: i'm going to work
Caption: towards a solution
Caption: now their input is also going to give me
Caption: other ideas or other avenues that i
Caption: might want to explore
Caption: that's also going to help me with my
Caption: feeling overwhelm my feeling of being
Caption: overwhelmed
Caption: because now
Caption: i've got a plan in place
Caption: i'm further going to help my
Caption: indecisiveness and my feeling of being
Caption: overwhelmed by creating and implementing
Caption: a plan
Caption: what i'm going to do is break this
Caption: large task down into small and
Caption: manageable tasks
Caption: and then
Caption: i'm going to set an intermediate
Caption: deadline for each of those tasks that's
Caption: going to help me with my deadline
Caption: anxiety
Caption: because now i'm going to be able to see
Caption: if i'm getting off track
Caption: and i'm going to be able to manage my
Caption: time more effectively
Caption: this is also going to help me with my
Caption: fear of failure because if i know that
Caption: i'm on track all the time or if i know
Caption: i'm getting off track i can ask for
Caption: other tasks to be reassigned i can ask
Caption: for another developer to come in and
Caption: give me support any of that kind of
Caption: stuff so i'm no longer worried that i'm
Caption: going to miss the deadline it's just not
Caption: going to happen anymore
Caption: my fear of evaluation oh sorry
Caption: i'm now in a good place to make a low
Caption: bar commitment even though this task is
Caption: much bigger than the
Caption: the tax task i can still get myself
Caption: going by saying i'll just do five
Caption: minutes because i've got all these
Caption: interim tasks that are much smaller
Caption: they're not as overwhelming to think
Caption: about as the full thing i don't have to
Caption: keep putting it off because i know
Caption: that there are smaller tasks that i can
Caption: do
Caption: the other thing my tasks are going to do
Caption: is allow me to choose the order i do
Caption: them carefully
Caption: so for some people
Caption: this looks like getting the least
Caption: attractive thing out the way right
Caption: someone i used to work with used to say
Caption: if you have to eat a frog eat it first
Caption: thing
Caption: there's another group of people who like
Caption: to get themselves motivated
Caption: feeling good about themselves and sign
Caption: themselves up by crossing off a few
Caption: little tasks you've got a couple of wins
Caption: in the bag you've had a couple little
Caption: things that you've ticked off and so
Caption: you're feeling good and ready to go on
Caption: to the other stuff
Caption: it doesn't really matter which type of
Caption: person you are
Caption: but if you understand which type then
Caption: you can choose your task order carefully
Caption: and that can also help you avoid
Caption: procrastination
Caption: now
Caption: i'm going to talk about prioritizing
Caption: your tasks by importance which sounds
Caption: like it kind of counterman's the one
Caption: we've just said
Caption: but they work together
Caption: because one of the caveats of choosing
Caption: your task order is that you can actually
Caption: use the subtasks to procrastinate on the
Caption: main task because procrastination is
Caption: very sneaky
Caption: i've
Caption: had a file open it's the file i'm
Caption: supposed to be working on i'm literally
Caption: working on it i'm like writing code
Caption: and it's still procrastination because
Caption: it isn't the task that i opened the file
Caption: to do
Caption: the reason i'm choosing to do this
Caption: little easy task
Caption: fixing up the way the header displays
Caption: is because i'm procrastinating on the
Caption: more daunting part of the task
Caption: so i'm going to avoid that by also
Caption: prioritizing if i'm the sort of person
Caption: that needs to psych myself up i'm going
Caption: to give myself permission to do one or
Caption: two little things
Caption: and then straight into the next one
Caption: so my fear of evaluation i'm going to
Caption: sort out by acknowledging that my work
Caption: is going to have some flaws
Caption: and the thing about my flaws is
Caption: they're not a reflection on my worth as
Caption: a person which is how it can feel
Caption: sometimes right
Caption: actually they're a learning opportunity
Caption: it's something that i'm gonna know
Caption: better for next time
Caption: now everything i've done so far actually
Caption: helps me with my task aversion because
Caption: i'm a lot clearer on what it is that i'm
Caption: doing
Caption: i don't have to
Caption: well probably won't have to
Caption: consult it straight away i might not
Caption: have to at all
Caption: if i do
Caption: i'm going to be able to be more focused
Caption: in what i'm searching for i'm not doing
Caption: generalized research i'm going to be
Caption: looking for specific problem solving
Caption: so that is also going to be addressed
Caption: all right so you can see that on the
Caption: surface these things look similar right
Caption: it was two tasks i was putting them off
Caption: i knew it was a bad idea
Caption: probably i'm just a bad person right
Caption: actually
Caption: if we look at it closely
Caption: what we can see is not only is this not
Caption: a moral failing on my part but the
Caption: reasons are so different that my
Caption: strategies need to be different to deal
Caption: with them as well and that's what i want
Caption: you to remember about procrastination
Caption: now i'm going to move on to the second
Caption: part of the presentation and talk about
Caption: distraction
Caption: now
Caption: i'm not going to be all down on
Caption: technology
Caption: i love technology but
Caption: i think it's important for us to admit
Caption: out loud that
Caption: in this wonderful world we've built of
Caption: instantaneous connection and
Caption: instantaneous content there are more
Caption: things competing for our attention than
Caption: ever before
Caption: and a lot of those things were designed
Caption: to specifically hook us in they're
Caption: leveraging that brain pattern to keep us
Caption: coming back again and again
Caption: right it's not really surprising under
Caption: these circumstances that we find
Caption: ourselves getting sucked into the vortex
Caption: maybe we're scrolling endlessly on
Caption: social media
Caption: maybe we're binging a whole tv series
Caption: maybe we're hooked on a notification
Caption: badge or we find ourselves unable to let
Caption: an email go unanswered even though we're
Caption: in the middle of a task
Caption: now this might seem innocuous
Caption: like does it really matter if you take
Caption: 30 seconds out of your day to answer an
Caption: email and actually it kind of does and
Caption: we're going to come back to that
Caption: you might also think
Caption: if i'm just sitting at home on the couch
Caption: after work shouldn't i be able to scroll
Caption: as much as i want
Caption: and yeah maybe you should
Caption: but where it becomes a problem is where
Caption: distraction stops us from doing the
Caption: things that are really important to us
Caption: so
Caption: in your personal life that might look
Caption: like you
Caption: not being as present for your kids as
Caption: you'd like it might look like you're not
Caption: fully pulling the weight in your
Caption: relationship
Caption: it might look like your house being in
Caption: an advanced state of chaos all the time
Caption: whatever it is it's likely to be
Caption: something that you're aware of and it's
Caption: likely to be something that causes you
Caption: pain and you know how we like to deal
Caption: with pain
Caption: procrastination
Caption: and that's how you end up in that loop
Caption: where at the end of the weekend you've
Caption: only got a tenth of your task done and
Caption: you know full well it's your own fault
Caption: because you spent most of the time
Caption: binging netflix
Caption: so
Caption: when this happens
Caption: we're most likely going to end up back
Caption: at
Caption: why are you like this i do it a lot
Caption: okay
Caption: like procrastination the most easy
Caption: solution easy solution to distraction
Caption: is better self-control again if you're a
Caption: better person you wouldn't spend as much
Caption: time mindlessly scrolling
Caption: now i'm going to go into a little bit of
Caption: this complicated behavioral science we
Caption: spoke about before
Caption: because i want to explain to you
Caption: something that's called ironic process
Caption: theory because this shows why
Caption: better self-control
Caption: mental abstinence
Caption: which is
Caption: using your self-control to stop yourself
Caption: from doing something that you actually
Caption: really want to do
Caption: isn't the answer to distraction
Caption: so it starts with this quote which is
Caption: from dostoyevsky
Caption: try to post for yourself this task
Caption: not to think of a white bear
Caption: and you will see that the cursed thing
Caption: will come to mind every minute
Caption: here's an outlook guys
Caption: so fast forwarding 120 odd years a
Caption: social psychologist called
Caption: daniel wegner decided to put this to the
Caption: task he really liked this quote so he
Caption: was like let's do an experiment
Caption: so he had two groups
Caption: one group was told specifically to think
Caption: of a white bear for five minutes
Caption: one group was told specifically to not
Caption: think of a white bear now the group that
Caption: was told not to failed miserably they
Caption: did it on average once a minute and
Caption: that's kind of what we're expecting
Caption: because this quote
Caption: rings true for most people right
Caption: the interesting part is
Caption: the second half of the experiment was to
Caption: tell both groups to think of the white
Caption: bear
Caption: and when they did that the group that
Caption: had initially suppressed the thoughts of
Caption: the white bear actually brought the
Caption: white beard to mind more readily than
Caption: the group who had been told to think of
Caption: it all along
Caption: what wegner found is that if you try and
Caption: suppress thoughts of something it
Caption: actually makes you more susceptible to
Caption: that thing
Caption: this is called behavioral rebound and it
Caption: works in everything from like trying to
Caption: control addiction to trying to suppress
Caption: your laughter
Caption: all right
Caption: so
Caption: there are a couple of techniques that
Caption: you can find for trying to deal with
Caption: intrusive thoughts that are brought to
Caption: mind that cause behavioral rebound but
Caption: they're mostly for things like if you're
Caption: quitting smoking
Caption: for distraction i've found the easiest
Caption: way to deal with it is just to remove
Caption: the stimulus
Caption: right
Caption: i know that i'm
Caption: susceptible to alerts and notifications
Caption: so what i'm going to do is simply stop
Caption: that from being able to happen
Caption: so i started with the biggest culprit
Caption: which was my phone
Caption: i just reconfigured it
Caption: so i uninstalled some apps goodbye
Caption: reddit goodbye wordscapes
Caption: and it didn't take long for me to be
Caption: broken from the habit of those two
Caption: things right
Caption: and actually an interesting thing
Caption: happened which is that my nieces asked
Caption: me if they could reinstall wordscapes
Caption: and i let them
Caption: because
Caption: they like to play it it's like all right
Caption: it's a problem for me but okay
Caption: and actually as it turns out it wasn't a
Caption: problem for me
Caption: i know it's there it's still there it's
Caption: still installed i never open it
Caption: they use it and they're the only ones
Caption: who do
Caption: and that's because i broke the habit
Caption: the second thing that i did with my
Caption: phone was to configure the notifications
Caption: so
Caption: i've always had lock screen notification
Caption: disabled that's just how i roll
Caption: but i did always have like an audio
Caption: alert that comes up you get a little
Caption: ping you're like oh what's this you go
Caption: and look at it right
Caption: so what i did with that was i actually
Caption: configured my do not disturb so that i
Caption: can have it switched on permanently
Caption: so what i let
Caption: come through
Caption: is nothing but phone calls i decided i
Caption: want pretty much anyone to always be
Caption: able to get me on the phone
Caption: maybe not your telemarketers but
Caption: if something important or crucial is
Caption: going to happen to my friends to my
Caption: family they're going to pick up the
Caption: phone and call me so anyone can always
Caption: call me but apart from that everything
Caption: else is completely silent so now the
Caption: only way that i know if i've got a text
Caption: message
Caption: an email from a non-work account
Caption: a notification from one of the like four
Caption: different instant messaging platforms i
Caption: have
Caption: is if i pick up my phone
Caption: and unlock it and explicitly look for it
Caption: this is a great time saver for me
Caption: because i'm just not picking up my phone
Caption: as much
Caption: excuse me
Caption: now
Caption: the next thing i'm going to talk about
Caption: was
Caption: is sorry the next thing i'm going to
Caption: talk about is actually
Caption: dealing with the internal triggers of
Caption: distraction so you can see the stuff
Caption: that i've talked about already is
Caption: external triggers there's a little noise
Caption: i'm prompted to pick up my phone but
Caption: there are also internal triggers and for
Caption: me they come up
Caption: in my moments of peak distractibility
Caption: and they're all internal so it's like i
Caption: finish one task and i'm gonna start
Caption: another
Caption: and i'm just gonna pick up my phone and
Caption: you know send a text
Caption: i've
Caption: finished a job that i was to do and i
Caption: feel like i need to reward myself
Caption: in those moments i'm most susceptible to
Caption: distractibility because i'm not just
Caption: going to pick up this thing and look at
Caption: it for a few seconds i'm going to keep
Caption: doing it
Caption: one of the ones i do a lot of the time
Caption: is like when something is loading or i'm
Caption: waiting for a two-factor authentication
Caption: something like that this is literally
Caption: like a 10-second period but i can't go
Caption: for those 10 seconds without being
Caption: entertained
Caption: i just can't
Caption: so all these triggers i need a different
Caption: approach to be able to
Caption: deal with now the first thing i did was
Caption: still configuring my tech
Caption: and that was to disable google discover
Caption: do you all know what google discover is
Caption: are you familiar with this it's it's
Caption: this thing
Caption: this is a little screenshot of mine
Caption: i haven't looked at the begonia yet i am
Caption: still interested
Caption: so this was a massive vortex for me
Caption: because actually google is really good
Caption: at knowing what i'm into begonias
Caption: cat memes
Caption: it's all good
Caption: and the problem was
Caption: that once i had disabled reddit it was
Caption: also popping up like a lot of well
Caption: obviously cat memes but also a lot of
Caption: like agony aunt content that i had
Caption: previously been seeing on reddit and i
Caption: ended up in a little bit of a spiral
Caption: where i was actually reading like reddit
Caption: aita posts but just screenshotted on a
Caption: content aggregator website
Caption: which is just plus all right google
Caption: discover you've got to go
Caption: okay
Caption: so i think i think at one point i had
Caption: looked at
Caption: an article that one of my friends had
Caption: posted and accidentally gave it the
Caption: impression that i care about infant
Caption: health care in any way which i don't
Caption: but apart from that it was nailing it
Caption: with the cat memes the agony art stuff
Caption: right so
Caption: what i did was to just
Caption: disable it and it was a bit of a problem
Caption: actually to try and do that because how
Caption: it worked for me was just a single swipe
Caption: from my home screen i had to google
Caption: quite deeply to work out how to turn
Caption: that functionality off but i managed it
Caption: once i'd done it
Caption: it was really noticeable just how many
Caption: times a day i reached for it because i
Caption: would swipe
Caption: and i'd do it a couple of times because
Caption: it hadn't worked and then i'd be like
Caption: oh i'm doing that thing again
Caption: and the interesting thing about this is
Caption: like before this content is actually
Caption: available to me at any time if i open a
Caption: new blank tab in chrome
Caption: it's just there that's the default
Caption: behavior but because i broke the little
Caption: reflex of swiping
Caption: it also
Caption: delivered a pretty big hit to the mental
Caption: part of it as well
Caption: now unfortunately
Caption: just disabling this one app is not
Caption: enough to deal completely with my
Caption: internal triggers of distraction
Caption: i also needed a strategy to be able to
Caption: do that
Caption: so the first thing is
Caption: i'm gonna have to notice the trigger
Caption: and ideally has to be in the moment you
Caption: can kind of do it as a retrospective
Caption: like all right i just put my phone down
Caption: after looking at it for 10 minutes when
Caption: i was just
Caption: waiting for two-factor authentication
Caption: whoops
Caption: but it's better if you notice it at the
Caption: time you're doing it
Caption: and for me
Caption: disabling google discover was a really
Caption: good thing for this because like i said
Caption: super noticeable when i tried to do it
Caption: and it didn't work
Caption: now the second step
Caption: is that i'm gonna explore the feelings
Caption: i'm not gonna judge myself and be like
Caption: oh you're a bad person
Caption: what i'm gonna do is just think about it
Caption: for a while
Caption: get curious wonder why i'm wanting to be
Caption: distracted and as before with my
Caption: procrastination when i'm thinking about
Caption: why i want to procrastinate
Caption: it is
Caption: easier for me to
Caption: understand and sit in the moment if i've
Caption: interrogated a little bit it's kind of
Caption: like wagner's second group of people
Caption: maybe first group of people the people
Caption: who are allowed to think about the bear
Caption: the whole time i'm not going to be
Caption: rebounding
Caption: because i'm allowing myself to think
Caption: about it i'm not trying to suppress that
Caption: thought
Caption: the third thing
Caption: is that i'm just going to wait for 10
Caption: minutes so this is like making a low bar
Caption: commitment to yourself with
Caption: procrastination you just say
Caption: i'm going to wait for 10 minutes it's
Caption: super easy to do
Caption: but actually
Caption: once you've noticed the trigger and
Caption: you've explored the feelings then the
Caption: waiting is usually enough of a period to
Caption: help you cool off
Caption: right
Caption: and you kind of know that you're not
Caption: supposed to be getting distracted so
Caption: it allows you to
Caption: sit with those feelings but not have to
Caption: feel guilty about them because you've
Caption: already made this bargain with yourself
Caption: if i wait for 10 minutes i still want to
Caption: do the thing after i'm allowed to do the
Caption: thing i don't have to feel guilty when i
Caption: do the thing because i already gave
Caption: myself permission i've already worked
Caption: through that
Caption: excuse me
Caption: all right
Caption: now i just want to talk specifically
Caption: about distractions at work because i
Caption: think they look a little bit different
Caption: to how distractions in your personal
Caption: life work
Caption: at work a lot of my distractions
Caption: kind of look a lot like plain old work
Caption: because that's mostly what they are
Caption: they're often a small task that's come
Caption: in
Caption: it's often pretty urgent
Caption: it's often something that is low impact
Caption: or low imp importance it's not usually
Caption: the big strategic stuff that i'm really
Caption: trying to work towards
Caption: and because distraction is just as
Caption: sneaky as procrastination
Caption: we think to ourselves oh yeah that is
Caption: important i will just do that thing
Caption: and where you end up
Caption: is in this cycle of churning stuff
Caption: through
Caption: and switching tasks frequently
Caption: now
Caption: the reason this is a problem for me is
Caption: because i am easily distracted so if
Caption: someone sends me an email my instinct is
Caption: to jump on what they do what they sent
Caption: to me and do it straight away okay
Caption: so my problem at work was pretty much
Caption: similar to in my personal life
Caption: it was notifications notifications
Caption: and notifications
Caption: because at work
Caption: we have email obviously
Caption: we have slack within our web team
Caption: we have
Caption: asana for our broader communications
Caption: team so get task notifications and then
Caption: we use teams for the whole organization
Caption: and anyone can talk to me through that
Caption: it's a lot of noise every day
Caption: so as with my phone
Caption: i change this up by just turning all
Caption: these off
Caption: so i now check it probably like three to
Caption: five times a day check all of those
Caption: channels
Caption: and apart from that
Caption: i have outlook closed
Caption: because if you just turn off the
Caption: notifications you can still see there's
Caption: a new email
Caption: i explicitly have to quit teams in the
Caption: system tray because if you just close it
Caption: it looks like it's closed but if you get
Caption: a notification
Caption: it pops up
Caption: and then i have slack muted and then
Caption: closed
Caption: because if you just close it you can
Caption: still see a little notification badge
Caption: and you can see what i was talking about
Caption: before with this
Caption: um
Caption: apps trying to hook us in right
Caption: i had to be quite ingenious with all
Caption: these things to try and stop them from
Caption: being able to reach me and distract me
Caption: um
Caption: sorry
Caption: as for asana what i did with that was i
Caption: turned off the notifications in slack so
Caption: we had an integration it would send you
Caption: a message every time that happened
Caption: and then i set up a rule in my email to
Caption: send all of the notifications to a
Caption: folder that i never look at so there's
Caption: now
Caption: 1166 unread emails
Caption: in that folder i'm pretty proud of that
Caption: thank you
Caption: and the reason i didn't just disable
Caption: them entirely is because assange's kind
Caption: of hard to use sometimes and sometimes
Caption: that is the best way of finding
Caption: something specific that i'm looking for
Caption: so didn't want to get rid of the emails
Caption: altogether but i don't want them
Caption: cluttering up my inbox
Caption: so
Caption: does this seem pretty extreme
Caption: it kind of seemed extreme to me
Caption: when i was first doing it so one of the
Caption: key things was to manage other people's
Caption: expectations so this is
Caption: my leader
Caption: our unit manager
Caption: everyone else in the web team and then a
Caption: couple of other people that i support
Caption: frequently
Caption: i told them that if they needed to get
Caption: me urgently then they should pick up the
Caption: phone and call me
Caption: and otherwise you can try your luck at
Caption: any time but i might not respond
Caption: straight away
Caption: and actually it did raise a few eyebrows
Caption: people were a bit like
Caption: so you're just not gonna let people talk
Caption: to you about work
Caption: but actually as it turns out people
Caption: really ever notice that i'm offline for
Caption: most of the day
Caption: and nobody
Caption: has ever picked up the phone to call me
Caption: it seemed pretty daunting to me when i
Caption: was first doing it and i think that was
Caption: because i was in this always on always
Caption: available mindset
Caption: which i think a lot of us are right
Caption: but it causes no inconvenience to anyone
Caption: else and it does make me a lot more
Caption: effective at work because like i said
Caption: i'm pretty easily distracted i will jump
Caption: on the nearest thing that came in
Caption: and then also because it stops me from
Caption: task switching so frequently
Caption: and now this is where we're going to
Caption: come back to
Caption: why does it matter if i take 30 seconds
Caption: out of my day to reply to that email
Caption: the reason it matters is because with
Caption: frequent task switching you're actually
Caption: raising your cognitive load okay so
Caption: cognitive load means it's going to be
Caption: harder for you to focus back on your
Caption: first task your brain is going to be
Caption: more tired and you're also going to be
Caption: much more likely to make a mistake
Caption: and that's a problem because i was doing
Caption: a lot of task switching
Caption: i think being at work can feel like
Caption: sharing out a single bucket of water
Caption: amongst all the fires
Caption: that are surrounding you
Caption: and you give them all just enough to
Caption: kind of keep them under control but it's
Caption: not enough to douse them usually
Caption: and you end up task switching a lot
Caption: because you need to put out your fires
Caption: now
Caption: to address this problem which i was
Caption: having a lot
Caption: i further switched up my day i'm going
Caption: to show you now my task tracking
Caption: software
Caption: and this is what it looked like before
Caption: i started doing all this stuff so you
Caption: can see here
Caption: i'm doing i mean tuesday was pretty good
Caption: actually
Caption: yay tuesday but like wednesday was a
Caption: complete mess
Caption: and these are all the tasks i'm doing
Caption: i'm doing like 11 minutes 25 minutes 26
Caption: minutes 17 minutes 22 minutes is because
Caption: i'm still available to anyone and
Caption: everyone at this time so i'm getting
Caption: emails in and replying to them
Caption: i'm getting teams things
Caption: i'm also in the mindset of
Caption: i'll just get that out the way
Caption: right because i've got a load of like
Caption: very small tasks they're very minor i
Caption: can get those done really quickly
Caption: and then i'll get on with the rest of my
Caption: day and actually what you can see here
Caption: is that i'm mostly not getting on with
Caption: the rest of my day
Caption: i'm ending up
Caption: not being able to focus really even that
Caption: well in the afternoon either i'm doing i
Caption: mean especially wednesday
Caption: what a problem but then all the rest of
Caption: them i'm still you know kind of managing
Caption: maybe an hour-ish a little bit more than
Caption: an hour and you can see where i'm most
Caption: effective
Caption: is after 4 pm on friday and that's
Caption: because nobody could talk to me
Caption: and
Caption: i'm working well and truly past six
Caption: because i have a lot of stuff that i
Caption: didn't get to do this week because i was
Caption: doing all this other little crappy stuff
Caption: okay
Caption: so here's what it looked like after i
Caption: started implementing this so you can see
Caption: i've still got mostly quite a smallish
Caption: task up front
Caption: and that's me doing my emails checking
Caption: teams checking slack
Caption: replying to anything that needs a bit of
Caption: back and forth
Caption: and then i'm also going into asana and
Caption: planning my day
Caption: and then i'm jumping straight into the
Caption: meaty stuff
Caption: i'm focusing for much longer periods of
Caption: time
Caption: and then when i come back after lunch
Caption: you can see
Caption: on some of the days like monday i'm
Caption: still doing the little tasks
Caption: but on other days i'm doing a lot more
Caption: focus in the afternoon as well
Caption: so it's like i'm still surrounded by
Caption: fires but actually now i'm just letting
Caption: them burn
Caption: and it turns out
Caption: i didn't need to give them as much
Caption: attention as i was they actually coped
Caption: just as well being left alone for a
Caption: while
Caption: the last thing i'm going to finish with
Caption: is a little bit of my asana so this is
Caption: the six months before this is how many
Caption: tasks i did
Caption: for context a task for us is anything
Caption: from like 15 minutes to four weeks so it
Caption: varies quite a lot
Caption: i'd say probably 60 of the tasks are
Caption: probably one to six hours right
Caption: so in the six months before i've done
Caption: 187 tasks this is about one and a
Caption: quarter tasks per day which is i don't
Caption: know it seems kind of okay i'm not sure
Caption: this is the six months after so it's
Caption: gone up like a little bit
Caption: but actually this encompasses the period
Caption: that i was on leave for over christmas
Caption: so actually now my daily rate
Caption: is now 1.93 which is a lot better than
Caption: 1.25 you know me but i was still kind of
Caption: refining my process at the time so in
Caption: the four months since then
Caption: i've now done 246 so i've done more
Caption: tasks in four months than i did in six
Caption: months and i'm now up to 2.93 tasks per
Caption: day
Caption: which is more than double what it was
Caption: before
Caption: i'm pretty impressed by it i hadn't
Caption: actually
Caption: i hadn't actually looked at these stats
Caption: before doing this talk i was just kind
Caption: of going with like the vibe feels more
Caption: productive i think i'm getting more done
Caption: turns out i was getting more done go me
Caption: all right
Caption: so i'm just going to finish up by
Caption: telling you what i think the key
Caption: takeaways are
Caption: so
Caption: i think understanding the reasons we
Caption: procrastinate and looking into it helps
Caption: us to choose the best technique to
Caption: overcome procrastination
Caption: distraction
Caption: can stop us from doing the things that
Caption: are really important to us whether
Caption: that's deploying a new feature
Caption: or letting the people we care about know
Caption: that we're fully present when we're with
Caption: them
Caption: we can deal with a lot of the external
Caption: triggers
Caption: of distraction by just configuring our
Caption: tech
Caption: we can deal with the internal triggers
Caption: not by suppressing our thoughts which
Caption: can lead to rebound
Caption: but by
Caption: being mindful and sitting in our
Caption: feelings in the moment
Caption: and you might get a bit of pushback if
Caption: you try and configure this stuff at work
Caption: but ultimately the results you're going
Caption: to get are going to be pretty good
Caption: and that's all thank you for coming
Caption: thank you ricky that was perfectly timed
Caption: well done
Caption: all right everyone just letting you know
Caption: that morning tea is immediately after
Caption: this talk
Caption: you can get refreshments from riverside
Caption: foia and north and south voyas i think
Caption: it's just out there if you want to go
Caption: grab it um the next session is due to
Caption: start at 11 25. we did start behind
Caption: schedule so i'm not sure if that's been
Caption: pushed back yet so keep an eye out for
Caption: when people start moving in
Caption: alright
Caption: see you back later
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our focus
Caption: my dream come true i've always wanted to
Caption: join scott handsome
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: sticky
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our focus
Caption: my dream come true i've always wanted to
Caption: join
Caption: someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very permanent accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the pink no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for target we
Caption: always try to go a little bit further
Caption: and we try to inspire each other by
Caption: learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: uh if you want to grow up in your career
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made sure dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: hello everyone and welcome to the second
Caption: talk of the day
Caption: so i'd like to introduce christy haynes
Caption: um he'll be giving the talk everyone's
Caption: confused about design and that's okay
Caption: so a bit about christy christie's had
Caption: over 18 years of experience in design
Caption: across a variety of delivery and
Caption: research roles
Caption: she's currently a ux design lead with
Caption: hbf health and has worked in both
Caption: enterprise and agency organizations in
Caption: australia and the uk
Caption: chris is proud to define herself as a
Caption: design generalist she's got a broad set
Caption: of skills a good dash of common sense
Caption: and experience that just helps get stuff
Caption: done
Caption: christy's passionate about levering does
Caption: leveraging design to help enable
Caption: high-performing cross-functional teams
Caption: she loves nothing better than working
Caption: with people in different roles to
Caption: unravel sticky problems and creating
Caption: innovative digital products and
Caption: experiences
Caption: okay thank you christy cool
Caption: thank you theresa um it actually makes
Caption: uh yeah i'm very proud that theresa was
Caption: actually able to introduce me today um
Caption: for those that don't know either of us
Caption: we go back a fair while so she's
Caption: actually a close friend so it means a
Caption: lot for you to introduce me um i want to
Caption: just thank the organizers the volunteers
Caption: and obviously our sponsors as well this
Caption: is my first ddd perth
Caption: conference so i thought why not come in
Caption: and do a 45 minute talk to start with so
Caption: it'll be fine
Caption: come along for the ride it'll be great
Caption: um right
Caption: so
Caption: let's get started
Caption: um what is design
Caption: so design is well that's a really simple
Caption: question but it's actually quite hard to
Caption: answer
Caption: it's something everybody's got
Caption: experience with in one way or another
Caption: and even if you had a room full of
Caption: designers and you asked them this very
Caption: question you'd get a whole wide range of
Caption: different answers back
Caption: so it's no wonder that everybody is
Caption: confused about design
Caption: so a couple of months ago i was looking
Caption: around online on the old facebooks as
Caption: you do
Caption: and i saw a facebook post from an online
Caption: design school that asked this very
Caption: question and i thought great that's
Caption: going to be two minutes of my 45 minute
Caption: talk i can probably talk through some of
Caption: the answers that they gave on that
Caption: facebook post
Caption: so let's have a squeeze at some of the
Caption: things that they are people said in the
Caption: facebook post comments
Caption: so design is function made beautiful
Caption: design is the intentional creation of
Caption: amazing effortless artifacts
Caption: all that we see is design
Caption: design is how things work
Caption: look feel and are used
Caption: so what comes to mind when you think of
Caption: design
Caption: so for some people it may mean things
Caption: like designing things like products
Caption: websites apps graphics
Caption: or it might be to say the way that
Caption: something looks or functions
Caption: and you'd be right these are all things
Caption: that we refer to as design but there are
Caption: only a few aspects of design
Caption: so about three years ago i was on mat
Caption: leave and i was getting a bit antsy and
Caption: i wanted to sort of watch a few design
Caption: presentations
Caption: and there was one by offering he's the
Caption: chief design officer over at anz bank
Caption: and what he talked through was a
Caption: framework that was developed by the
Caption: carnegie carnegie school of mellon
Caption: school of design in the 1990s and it
Caption: talks about four orders of design
Caption: so these aren't levels there's no
Caption: hierarchy here but they're just four
Caption: types of problem spaces that design can
Caption: help with
Caption: and i found it really useful in the way
Caption: that it broke this broad concept of
Caption: design into something that was just a
Caption: little bit easier to understand because
Caption: design at its core is about problem
Caption: solving
Caption: so these are our four orders of design
Caption: they look based loosely around product
Caption: type and ordered around complexity level
Caption: now this is all well and good but if you
Caption: actually went up to a designer today and
Caption: said hey what ordered you work in
Caption: they'll probably look at you a little
Caption: bit weird and have no idea what you were
Caption: talking about
Caption: so it's not something that designers uh
Caption: talk about in their day-to-day but it's
Caption: a great concept to help explain the
Caption: broad landscape of design
Caption: so our first order here is called
Caption: symbols and this is all about visual
Caption: communication and it's most often the
Caption: area that people associate with design
Caption: so this is all about the visual things
Caption: people can see
Caption: so this has things like illustration
Caption: typography
Caption: photography posters all of that sort of
Caption: good stuff
Caption: and it's everything that's related to
Caption: the world of graphic design visual
Caption: design and information design
Caption: our second order here is called products
Caption: and this is where objects are this is
Caption: includes objects that people physically
Caption: interact with
Caption: this is where form and function meet
Caption: it's a world of product design and
Caption: industrial design
Caption: and just to confuse things a little bit
Caption: more because everybody's already
Caption: confused about design so hey ho
Caption: um physical product design does not
Caption: equal digital product design so this
Caption: sits in our next order which is
Caption: our order of interactions
Caption: and this deals with the experience of
Caption: people and things over time
Caption: so it's often tied in with our first
Caption: order of design and that's where you see
Caption: your user interface elements appear
Caption: but it delivers on interactions services
Caption: and experiences
Caption: so this is our world of service design
Caption: user experience design ux design
Caption: or and digital product design
Caption: and now we're in our fourth order this
Caption: is called systems and this is our most
Caption: complex order of all and we're in in
Caption: this we're designing for things like
Caption: businesses
Caption: learning experiences
Caption: systems
Caption: cultures
Caption: organizations and even cities
Caption: so this is a this is about how groups of
Caption: people and things interact with other
Caption: groups of people and things
Caption: and this is our world of strategic
Caption: design business design and
Caption: organizational design
Caption: now this is all well and good and i
Caption: always love a good framework but let's
Caption: have a look at this in action
Caption: we're going to talk about apple
Caption: okay so
Caption: um i've done this i've practiced this
Caption: talk a few times and uh i've had some
Caption: positive and negative reactions whenever
Caption: i mention apple to people so um can i
Caption: get a hands up for who's an apple fan in
Caption: the audience who digs apple here
Caption: got a few people thought they might be
Caption: coming to a design talk
Caption: who's not a fan who's like boo hiss bad
Caption: apple
Caption: yeah
Caption: and who's ambivalent who's like
Caption: yeah awesome okay we've got a good
Caption: mixture in here so this is going to be
Caption: good um this isn't sponsored by apple by
Caption: the way but if anybody is in the
Caption: audience like i'm always open to some
Caption: freebies so that's good
Caption: so we're going to go back into our
Caption: orders here we're going to talk about
Caption: our first orders order of design which
Caption: is symbols or visual communication
Caption: so in the 1990s apple was actually in a
Caption: pretty bad state people actually thought
Caption: the company was going to go under
Caption: there was no iphone there was no ipod
Caption: there was no ipad no imac and then while
Caption: steve jobs waited on these products to
Caption: launch he wanted something that would
Caption: remind people about the qualities that
Caption: were called to the apple brand
Caption: and this is where our think different
Caption: campaign uh comes in
Caption: so here you'll see one of the print ads
Caption: that was uh that was created and there
Caption: were a whole series of print ads that
Caption: went with this as well as a television
Caption: commercial
Caption: and it's really powerful because here
Caption: you can because of the emotions and
Caption: memories that this actually conveys so
Caption: there's no product shots here there's no
Caption: talk of any product benefits there's
Caption: just three things a historical figure
Caption: the apple logo and the words think
Caption: different
Caption: so this is a branding campaign pure and
Caption: simple and it's one of the most popular
Caption: apple campaigns to this day
Caption: so now we're looking at our second order
Caption: here and this is our order of products
Caption: or physical objects
Caption: so here we're designing two a broader
Caption: set of challenges which might mean
Caption: materials supply chain logistics do i
Caption: need to change my microphone yep
Caption: that's okay
Caption: which is good okay cool
Caption: um right here we are designing to a
Caption: broader set of challenges so you're
Caption: looking at things like materials supply
Caption: chain logistics ergonomics packaging and
Caption: more
Caption: so the apple packaging itself is a
Caption: sensory experience your first
Caption: interaction with this thing is actually
Caption: how it looks
Caption: pack this packaging is designed to be as
Caption: visually appealing as the thing that
Caption: sits inside it
Caption: so every line on this box is clean it's
Caption: elegant it's minimalist it's white
Caption: packaging it's simple in a world of
Caption: clutter
Caption: so apple actually pay attention as much
Caption: attention to the small stuff as they do
Caption: the big stuff
Caption: so that box that gets the same amount of
Caption: attention as the device inside it
Caption: so did you know that there's actually a
Caption: designer or designers that are employed
Caption: to create design and test hundreds of
Caption: prototype boxes
Caption: so this just isn't about aesthetics here
Caption: it's also about a package that's easy
Caption: for customers to open it's easy for them
Caption: to identify the components parts inside
Caption: it and it's easy for them to start using
Caption: so it's a process that's focused first
Caption: and foremost on the customer it's not
Caption: focused on for example to prevent
Caption: shoplifting
Caption: now we're getting into our third order
Caption: here and this is our order of
Caption: interactions and services now i'm going
Caption: to spend a little bit more time talking
Caption: about this order because it's probably
Caption: where most of your designers will
Caption: actually be working in
Caption: so we're going to think about the
Caption: experience of buying from an apple store
Caption: from a physical store
Caption: so you're going to have a trigger
Caption: there's going to be something that makes
Caption: you want to buy that apple product
Caption: maybe it's an ad that you've seen maybe
Caption: it's a friend of a family member that
Caption: you've been recommended it from
Caption: you'll do some research you'll make your
Caption: way to the store maybe you're catching a
Caption: train
Caption: you'll enter the store you'll talk to
Caption: somebody about what you're after you'll
Caption: purchase your apple product you'll leave
Caption: the store you'll go home you'll open up
Caption: the box
Caption: so this whole end-to-end experience and
Caption: these touch points and interactions and
Caption: emotions that are what we're designing
Caption: for in this order
Caption: so in this order our designers look at
Caption: three main areas we've got people
Caption: process and technology
Caption: so first of all the people so it's not
Caption: just about the customers but the people
Caption: that work at apple
Caption: this is about maintaining empathy for
Caption: everybody that's involved in the process
Caption: and so by trying to understand all sides
Caption: we can make human-centered critical
Caption: decisions in designing the experience
Caption: and we also look at process so these are
Caption: the standard procedures to operate a
Caption: business
Caption: so for this apple example we'll look at
Caption: things like
Caption: how do the staff talk and interact with
Caption: the customers so what are their selling
Caption: tactics
Caption: how are the staff rusted on for example
Caption: what happens during peak hours
Caption: and what are the different roles in the
Caption: store who does what
Caption: and by understanding the current process
Caption: and the business requirements we can
Caption: align and arm people in the business
Caption: with the knowledge and the tools to help
Caption: improve the experience
Caption: and the third one we look at is
Caption: technology so what's needed to deliver
Caption: the experience
Caption: so
Caption: what technology is apple using to help
Caption: deliver the service seamlessly so do
Caption: they have an efficient point of sale
Caption: system are we tracking deliveries once
Caption: they leave the store or the warehouse we
Caption: look at technology so we can actually
Caption: understand what are the touch points to
Caption: deliver the service and what can be done
Caption: to deliver a better improved service
Caption: now we're getting into our fourth order
Caption: this is our fourth order of design where
Caption: we're reaching into business design and
Caption: innovation
Caption: so apple is in fact a service business
Caption: it's got everything from the app store
Caption: too and i'm going to take a breath here
Caption: apple news apple books apple tv apple
Caption: movies apple music apple pay iclouds
Caption: itunes and much more all right so this
Caption: is where it gets its revenue so it's not
Caption: just about selling laptops and phones
Caption: it's about selling people constant
Caption: ongoing subscriptions for the things
Caption: that they can do on their devices
Caption: it's an ecosystem that's designed to
Caption: suck you in and never let you leave so
Caption: by buying that iphone it's almost like
Caption: that gateway drug into the apple
Caption: experience
Caption: so apple innovate through reinvention
Caption: and they just make it slick
Caption: so they want to take innovation to the
Caption: next level by making its product
Caption: features better and to work seamlessly
Caption: across multiple devices
Caption: so this leads us to now how apple
Caption: designs their business for innovation
Caption: so in 1997 uh when jobs returned to
Caption: apple this had a conventional structure
Caption: this is a structure that you see on the
Caption: left here it was divided into those
Caption: business units
Caption: so he changed it to the structure on the
Caption: right where the organization was
Caption: restructured to align to areas of
Caption: expertise and since tim cook has taken
Caption: over it has changed slightly again
Caption: so they rely on organizational design to
Caption: have a crucial part in the success for
Caption: innovation where they're able to compete
Caption: with other companies like google samsung
Caption: microsoft ibm and many more
Caption: but if you're anything like me
Caption: you probably still have questions
Caption: like
Caption: when did things start getting so
Caption: complicated when do we start needing all
Caption: of these different types of designers
Caption: and when did they start popping up in
Caption: all of these different organizations
Caption: so i blame the year 2013 right so i want
Caption: you to think back to 2013 and think
Caption: about what you were doing
Caption: it was almost a decade ago
Caption: it was a very non-pandemic type of time
Caption: it was a much simpler time back then
Caption: but it's got a lot to answer for
Caption: now i didn't know if i'd be losing
Caption: people at this point so you've hit the
Caption: funny gif and meme section of my talk
Caption: which is cool
Caption: so
Caption: 2013 was when this guy came into office
Caption: so he was our 28th prime minister like i
Caption: said 2013 had a lot to answer for um
Caption: thanks to miley twerking first entered
Caption: the oxford dictionary so that's actually
Caption: in the dictionary now thanks to her
Caption: the worst wedding ever happened on game
Caption: of thrones uh my partner's now making me
Caption: re-watch all the game of thrones uh
Caption: series at the moment so i thought that
Caption: was quite apt
Caption: um and back in 2013 i read a wide
Caption: magazine article which at the time i
Caption: didn't think too much of i thought i
Caption: thought that's interesting i wonder
Caption: what's going to happen off of that and
Caption: just sort of moved on with my day
Caption: but little did i know that that was
Caption: actually a key moment in terms of what
Caption: design meant or represented to
Caption: businesses
Caption: so this is what it was entitled it was
Caption: called big corporations are buying
Caption: design firms in droves
Caption: right and the first opening line in this
Caption: was the significance of does of design
Caption: in business is ballooning
Caption: so 2013 is the year that accenture a
Caption: global consulting firm
Caption: buys design giant fjord so fjord are a
Caption: london-based global design and
Caption: innovation firm
Caption: now bigger companies have been acquiring
Caption: smaller companies since forever
Caption: but it was about this time that design
Caption: agencies and firms started to become
Caption: acquired by large consultant companies
Caption: and so it wasn't just large advertising
Caption: marketing and creative groups
Caption: and so fast forward to today so design
Caption: has changed it's now being recognized by
Caption: companies and businesses as something
Caption: that can provide better business and
Caption: customer outcomes
Caption: and so what this means is now we're
Caption: seeing a change in the type of designers
Caption: that we're seeing in organizations so
Caption: say about 10 years ago they were much
Caption: more visual digital and web designers
Caption: and now you're seeing more strategic
Caption: experience and service designers
Caption: so what does this mean for you right the
Caption: projects that you work on and the
Caption: designers that you actually work with
Caption: so it not only comes down to
Caption: understanding what is design all of
Caption: those cool for four orders that we've
Caption: just gone through
Caption: but it's about getting a rough idea of
Caption: what the design process is like and
Caption: where different designers can crop up in
Caption: your process
Caption: now when we talk through the process
Caption: today i'll mainly be talking through our
Caption: third order of design so this is mainly
Caption: when we're dealing with ux designers
Caption: service designers product designers etc
Caption: so this is my area the area that i sit
Caption: in and most of the uh like i said before
Caption: where most of your designers will
Caption: probably sit in
Caption: so
Caption: this is what it looks like when you've
Caption: got designers usually explaining design
Caption: processes we tend to look a little bit
Caption: like that
Caption: it does feel like there's like a million
Caption: different design frameworks and
Caption: methodologies out there out there that
Caption: step through this process but
Caption: um but the easiest one and the most
Caption: common one we tend to refer to
Caption: is our good old double diamond and this
Caption: is great because you can chuck in double
Caption: diamond into google and this you know is
Caption: generally what you'll get back so
Caption: um it was done in 2004 it was created by
Caption: the uk design council
Caption: um and it's very well known with
Caption: designers so if you ever want to talk to
Caption: a designer about this they can run you
Caption: through it
Caption: so it basically describes our two modes
Caption: of thinking that we do as designers this
Caption: is where we're going wide we're
Caption: diverging
Caption: and then we'll converge and we'll go
Caption: narrow
Caption: might be a new speaker post who knows um
Caption: so the first assignment is really about
Caption: if we're figuring out if we're doing the
Caption: right things right so this is why we're
Caption: going to go right wide with our
Caption: discovery search
Caption: we're going to converge and we're going
Caption: to go narrow we're going to define our
Caption: research themes our insights and our
Caption: opportunity areas
Caption: and then we're going to go into our
Caption: second diamond so this is about building
Caption: the things right so we go wide we
Caption: diverge we go wide with our ideas we're
Caption: starting to set the design vision and
Caption: north star and then we're going to
Caption: converge and we're going to go narrow
Caption: and this is where we're prototyping
Caption: we're testing we're learning we're
Caption: iterating we're rinsing and repeating
Caption: until huzzah we have our solution
Caption: but i have a problem with this approach
Caption: it's too design centric
Caption: i think it's useful because it gives all
Caption: the good stuff that you get with
Caption: converging and diverging etc but it
Caption: suggests that we've actually got a final
Caption: solution at the end that it sets up the
Caption: expectation that everything's completed
Caption: and it's handed off for implementation
Caption: to our dev teams
Caption: that last diamond is way too simplified
Caption: in the real world of delivery
Caption: so this is why i personally prefer the
Caption: triple diamond which was produced by
Caption: zendesk and this is what it looks like
Caption: so at the start of our third diamond
Caption: here we're confident it's the right
Caption: solution at this point we've gone
Caption: through our discovery process and we
Caption: know it's there but it needs further
Caption: refinement
Caption: so let's zoom into this last diamond a
Caption: little bit more
Caption: there we go
Caption: this diamond actually marks the start of
Caption: our agile sprints where we're building
Caption: our products through to our launch and
Caption: it's not about doing a handoff
Caption: here we're refining and we're filling in
Caption: more details as we're progressing
Caption: through our sprints
Caption: and our des are investigating technical
Caption: solutions while our designers are
Caption: creating prototypes and conducting
Caption: usability tests
Caption: and as we progress we can see the
Caption: uncertainty is decreasing over time and
Caption: we're honing into that right solution
Caption: and we're still testing throughout just
Caption: to see how customers are responding
Caption: through our product so this test and
Caption: respond
Caption: and we're tweaking accordingly
Caption: and as we progress uncertainty is
Caption: decreasing over time and we're starting
Caption: to hone into that right solution
Caption: now we should be refining our solution
Caption: as we're progressing we're really
Caption: starting to hone in but towards the end
Caption: that flexibility for change decreases
Caption: and at the end it's that last little
Caption: bits of optimizations that we're
Caption: actually accounting for
Caption: now it's important to remember and
Caption: anyone that's been involved in this
Caption: process it's never linear
Caption: it feels a little bit messy sometimes
Caption: sometimes there's features that you may
Caption: discover that need to go back into the
Caption: discovery process for example
Caption: so now we've got a good understanding of
Caption: the process let's talk about some of the
Caption: different designers you'll get across
Caption: this process and where do they
Caption: sit i'm going to take a bit of water
Caption: here just
Caption: hold on
Caption: right
Caption: so now we're back into our triple
Caption: diamond the full triple diamond
Caption: and here is an example of what our hbf
Caption: projects look like and how our designers
Caption: sit in the process
Caption: so we're actually in that last little
Caption: validation stage at the moment
Caption: so our service designers and our ux
Caption: researchers are performing heuristic
Caption: reviews and assessments with some squads
Caption: and our in squad product designers our
Caption: ux uis are working through bug fixes and
Caption: improvements
Caption: so as a team we're actually honing in on
Caption: our final solution but our flexibility
Caption: for changes definitely decreasing as
Caption: we're getting closer to our roll out
Caption: so let's talk about collaborating with
Caption: designers in this process
Caption: so it's really important to remember
Caption: that designers don't hold the monopoly
Caption: over how we design and build products or
Caption: even how we innovate
Caption: remember we need to collaborate with our
Caption: experts with you guys and ladies and
Caption: gents and everyone in this room
Caption: so the reason why we need you
Caption: we need to make sure that we're design
Caption: what we're designing is not only
Caption: desirable but it's also feasible to
Caption: create and viable for the business
Caption: so if there's no collaboration there we
Caption: end up missing two key areas our
Caption: feasibility and our viability
Caption: so innovation and great products can't
Caption: happen in isolation
Caption: and it's certainly not about throwing
Caption: things over the fence and designing and
Caption: developing
Caption: without collaboration
Caption: so collaboration is key to creating
Caption: innovative products and services
Caption: so for those that are interested this is
Caption: what we call a dvf framework
Caption: it also is referred to as three lenses
Caption: of innovation and it was done by
Caption: originally a company called ideo
Caption: and there's been a lot of talk recently
Caption: about a fourth lens uh this is for
Caption: sustainability and this is where we're
Caption: looking at including social and
Caption: environmental awarenesses into our
Caption: designs as well
Caption: right let's go through some practical
Caption: tips because i'm all about practical
Caption: tips
Caption: that can help improve collaboration with
Caption: your designers
Caption: so first see your design team as your
Caption: true partner in crime so we can help you
Caption: understand customer needs and can help
Caption: you influence the product design and
Caption: direction
Caption: and provide constructive feedback so we
Caption: love getting good useful um feedback and
Caption: fresh ideas but it needs to be delivered
Caption: in a way which is actually useful so
Caption: things like i love it is always great
Caption: but making sure you tell us why you love
Caption: it the same thing goes with uh i don't
Caption: like it
Caption: make sure that you've got that backing
Caption: there for why you don't like it
Caption: so providing a reason will always help
Caption: your designers but you need to make sure
Caption: it's with the lens of your customer
Caption: make sure it's objective feedback and if
Caption: you've got the data there to support it
Caption: even better
Caption: so be upfront about constraints
Caption: so your designers should be getting the
Caption: feedback from you throughout the design
Caption: process and if they're not definitely
Caption: hit them up about that
Caption: speak up about technical and business
Caption: constraints as well so when we know
Caption: about these
Caption: it helps us work with you to find an
Caption: alternative solution
Caption: but it's really important to be
Caption: considerate and to make sure that
Caption: upfront constraints don't stifle
Caption: creativity and innovation so make sure
Caption: you work with your designers as a team
Caption: to overcome those constraints
Caption: review design work thoroughly so this is
Caption: especially true for our visual designers
Caption: so details matter here right you they
Caption: may your designers may think that
Caption: they've specked out everything but more
Caption: than likely they have actually missed
Caption: something
Caption: so the same thing goes for those that
Caption: are working with design systems
Caption: so make sure you're factoring it in time
Caption: with your feedback
Caption: quite often we work hand to mouth
Caption: especially when we're working in squads
Caption: right where all the deliverables are
Caption: really urgent
Caption: but this actually leads to problems
Caption: later on so when suddenly it just
Caption: becomes a just get it done sort of
Caption: scenario we may miss opportunities for
Caption: things that need to be tested
Caption: now out of all of these points if
Caption: there's any one point that's probably
Caption: the most important this is it this is
Caption: about getting involved
Caption: so observe your research sessions make
Caption: the time to observe them listen to the
Caption: customer feedback and even your debriefs
Caption: from your designers
Caption: so discuss with them what are their next
Caption: steps
Caption: highlight any technical or business
Caption: constraints and but leave it with them
Caption: to make the design decisions
Caption: right so i actually know i've got a few
Caption: designers in the audience today so i
Caption: don't think i haven't forgotten about
Caption: you
Caption: and hopefully some are watching online
Caption: as well
Caption: now
Caption: just think
Caption: what if you gave the same care and
Caption: attention to the people that you work
Caption: with as you do your end users right so
Caption: find out the pain points and needs for
Caption: the people that you work with
Caption: so talk to them take them out for coffee
Caption: maybe beer or wine always open for that
Caption: maybe some people like something a
Caption: little bit more formal
Caption: i've even seen designers use empathy
Caption: maps before to better understand their
Caption: teammates
Caption: so understand maybe the pressures that
Caption: your product owner is under so what
Caption: metrics are important to them what are
Caption: they trying to achieve
Caption: what are the pain points for your
Caption: developers is rework a problem for them
Caption: what's going to make their life a lot
Caption: easier
Caption: so by understanding the people that you
Caption: work with
Caption: just as well as you do your users you
Caption: can actually establish better workflows
Caption: that will provide better outcomes and
Caption: will end up having a better happier
Caption: working relationships
Caption: so be like bruce lee this is very zen be
Caption: like bruce lee be flexible like water
Caption: so your design documentations and
Caption: workflows will change from project to
Caption: project from team to team and you need
Caption: to adapt to what works best for your
Caption: team
Caption: so your team shouldn't adapt to you i
Caption: mean sure sometimes you may have
Caption: suggestions to actually uh how a
Caption: different approach may help everything
Caption: but in general we're a piece of a larger
Caption: puzzle so be like water be adaptable
Caption: your design will never be done sounds a
Caption: little bit depressing but this is where
Caption: you need to be strong this is where
Caption: resilience is key
Caption: so as a designer our job isn't done once
Caption: our screens and prototypes are done
Caption: you're going to find that the real
Caption: challenge and i'm finding this at the
Caption: moment is when people start poking
Caption: around in your designs discovering holes
Caption: and use cases that you haven't even
Caption: thought of
Caption: and so as this happens you need to make
Caption: sure that you work harder to accommodate
Caption: these requirements iterating on your
Caption: designs
Caption: so our role this is because our role as
Caption: designers is to create experiences that
Caption: people actually use it's not about
Caption: creating mock-ups or concepts
Caption: so we need to be responsible for the
Caption: things we create we're an important part
Caption: of what is produced and used by the
Caption: people that we champion
Caption: because of this we're going to
Caption: continually keep iterating and improving
Caption: and evolving our designs and they'll
Caption: never be done but at the end of the day
Caption: that's a great thing
Caption: so it's not just about design either so
Caption: how can designers help make sure that we
Caption: deliver on a great product so this is
Caption: where we're going to get our hands dirty
Caption: and we're going to help provide feedback
Caption: on what's being built
Caption: so for example the designers in our web
Caption: squad at the moment over at hbs have
Caption: been doing device testing and i've had a
Caption: heap of people come up to me going but
Caption: why are you guys doing testing like
Caption: doesn't that sit with the developers and
Caption: the testers
Caption: um but designers actually have an
Caption: intimate knowledge of the product of the
Caption: end user and what should be built right
Caption: and they know how those dots connect
Caption: throughout that whole end to end
Caption: experience so use that to your advantage
Caption: so designers this means you might have
Caption: to get intimate with things like for
Caption: example jira
Caption: make sure the acceptance criteria is
Caption: correct make sure that that link in that
Caption: ticket is linking through to your figma
Caption: file or your sketch file
Caption: make sure those screenshots are correct
Caption: so all of these things work to help your
Caption: team and also help make sure that you
Caption: deliver on a great product and
Caption: experience
Caption: so less is more
Caption: so as we desire as designers we design
Caption: for an ideal state
Caption: right our future state so in the real
Caption: world not all of our features will make
Caption: it into our mvp a minimal viable product
Caption: that's built at the end
Caption: so as the project progresses you're
Caption: going to find that your product owner is
Caption: going to prioritize features and as this
Caption: happens designers are going to see their
Caption: work shrink and shrink and shrink and
Caption: shrink until everything's sort of thrown
Caption: out of it at the end of the day at the
Caption: end of the boat
Caption: so this is where a design mindset change
Caption: is needed so this should be seen as an
Caption: opportunity rather than an attack
Caption: so we can really work to refine out
Caption: these mvp features and really make sure
Caption: that we're working closely with our
Caption: teams to build this out
Caption: now just like the last a lot of
Caption: points that i went through if there's
Caption: any one that you want to take away with
Caption: you this is probably it's about bringing
Caption: our teams along for the ride
Caption: and see there's a roller coaster there
Caption: so sometimes our teams aren't involved
Caption: in our discovery process
Caption: sometimes they don't get to see things
Caption: like usability tests or hear from our
Caption: end users right
Caption: so as designers we represent the voice
Caption: of the customer we've got a really
Caption: important part in making sure that
Caption: goodness spreads across our teams
Caption: so it might be things like playing back
Caption: verbatim feedback that we've had in our
Caption: user testing sessions
Caption: we may present test results back in some
Caption: things like uh we've got showcases for
Caption: example at hbf we play back our research
Caption: findings and those
Caption: and if you're able to play back videos
Caption: where people can hear it from the
Caption: horse's mouth that's even better
Caption: so when you can make sure you involve
Caption: your teams so it's really difficult
Caption: sometimes because there is a tension
Caption: between just getting the stuff done
Caption: making sure we're achieving our sprint
Caption: goals making sure we're getting that
Caption: burn down looking really good
Caption: but in the bigger picture we're going to
Caption: have products that provide a better
Caption: experiences for our teams if they know
Caption: who they're designing them for and who
Caption: they're building them for as well
Caption: so as designers it's not just about us
Caption: understanding our end users it's also
Caption: the role of the business to understand
Caption: the end users and as designers we need
Caption: to make sure we're better at spreading
Caption: and sharing that knowledge and
Caption: understanding of our customers
Caption: so these tactics that i've talked
Caption: through are really aimed at improving
Caption: collaboration right so we know that
Caption: collaboration is really key for
Caption: high-performing cross-functional teams
Caption: but it also improves something that we
Caption: call design maturity
Caption: so what is design maturity
Caption: so design maturity is the way to which
Caption: business businesses incorporate
Caption: understand and use design
Caption: so the more mature an organization the
Caption: more likely that innovation better
Caption: customer experiences and business
Caption: benefits will happen
Caption: so there's been a bunch of reports and
Caption: models that have been done on design
Caption: maturity there's been one through the
Caption: nielsen norman group that's very ux
Caption: focused there was one three years ago
Caption: through a company called envision and
Caption: one done about five years ago through
Caption: mckinsey
Caption: so we're going to have a quick look at
Caption: the envision maturity scale here
Caption: so this is the maturity scale that was
Caption: done by envision so here you can see as
Caption: we move through different levels of
Caption: design maturity so they're those big
Caption: dots you see on the screen there
Caption: the benefits of design
Caption: and the adoption of design in the
Caption: business increase
Caption: so these circles represent the
Caption: proportions of businesses for each of
Caption: these maturity stages in the study
Caption: so for example that little dot that you
Caption: see at the top right there
Caption: that shows that five percent of com
Caption: companies were at the top level of
Caption: design maturity so in this study that's
Caption: 110 businesses out of 2200
Caption: so let's look at each of these levels
Caption: let's go into level ones
Caption: so these have the lowest level of design
Caption: maturity but they actually make up the
Caption: largest proportion at 41
Caption: so these are the companies where design
Caption: is just seen as pixels on a screen
Caption: so here there's a real disconnect
Caption: between what designers design and what
Caption: developers actually produce and so this
Caption: is a symptom of a lack of collaboration
Caption: when we hit our level two so this is a
Caption: level two throughout 21 here this is
Caption: where collaboration with these
Caption: organizations was improving where
Caption: designers and non-designers are starting
Caption: to work together a lot more
Caption: so here you're seeing more things like
Caption: integrated tooling user research user
Caption: testing you're probably seeing some
Caption: personas around the business
Caption: and you're generally hearing a lot more
Caption: chit chat about design in the business
Caption: now
Caption: we're going to look at our level threes
Caption: here they're at 21
Caption: as well but this is where design starts
Caption: to become scalable where there's
Caption: established things like processes roles
Caption: responsibilities documentation all of
Caption: that sort of stuff so this is where
Caption: design operates in more complex
Caption: companies and product ecosystems
Caption: so with level threes you're seeing more
Caption: things like design systems written
Caption: briefs um and more design ceremonies
Caption: when we look at our level fours so this
Caption: is where we're starting to get a little
Caption: bit smaller here this is uh twelve
Caption: percent of companies in this survey that
Caption: um envisioned in
Caption: so this is where you're starting to see
Caption: a lot more design experimentation and
Caption: it's all about data driven design
Caption: so this is where you're probably
Caption: starting to see the start of a design
Caption: strategy practice this is where you're
Caption: probably going to see more market
Caption: research and design vision development
Caption: have happening and you're probably
Caption: seeing design operations being
Caption: formalized to support the design
Caption: practice as well
Caption: and our last little dot at the top there
Caption: that's our level five so this is nirvana
Caption: right so this is level five it sounded
Caption: really australian banana anyway
Caption: um this is our ultimate level of design
Caption: maturity right this is only where five
Caption: percent of the companies in the survey
Caption: we're playing so this is where design is
Caption: actually used to help business strategy
Caption: where we're doing exploratory user
Caption: research we're doing trend spotting and
Caption: futures research we're experimenting
Caption: we're testing for product market fit and
Caption: producing things like vision artifacts
Caption: so the majority of places that i've
Caption: worked at i'd say would be between a
Caption: level one and three so that's not a bad
Caption: thing it just means design is a function
Caption: in the business is in its early days
Caption: and so it's really important to remember
Caption: you can't just jump from a level one to
Caption: a level five if only if it was that easy
Caption: it's a real gradual progression that he
Caption: requires a huge amount of effort and a
Caption: lot of the the business uh buying from
Caption: uh the business as well
Caption: so it can take years to move from one
Caption: stage to the next
Caption: but it happens every day and still in
Caption: small steps i do seem to remember off
Caption: the top of my head but don't quote me i
Caption: think it takes probably about 30 years
Caption: possibly to reach a level 5 organization
Caption: so aside from collaboration what can
Caption: help right so here are some tips from
Caption: that report
Caption: and some examples of what we've been
Caption: doing over at hbf
Caption: so design needs to be supported at a
Caption: leadership level so when it's seen as
Caption: more than just pixels on a screen and
Caption: it's recognized as a part of the
Caption: business a critical part of the business
Caption: there's opportunity to use design to
Caption: innovate
Caption: so it's something that we do have at hbf
Caption: so we've got support from our general
Caption: managers in the business and we've got
Caption: an executive general manager of member
Caption: experience
Caption: so they actually understand and speak to
Caption: the value of design and so having this
Caption: support actually means that hpf has
Caption: actually adopted design and see it as
Caption: key for improving the customer and
Caption: member experiences
Caption: so higher experience design leaders
Caption: right isn't this typically what you
Caption: think of a designer you know wearing
Caption: black glasses and a black outfit
Caption: the more senior a design leadership the
Caption: greater the return on the design
Caption: investment so who should you be hiring
Caption: for right so you need design leaders
Caption: that know their craft they can inspire
Caption: their team and they can make a strong
Caption: case for design at the highest levels of
Caption: business
Caption: so at hbf we've got a chat to lead and
Caption: we've also got a gm of member experience
Caption: strategy and they're part of those
Caption: critical conversations and this actually
Caption: gives design a voice in the business
Caption: where it can actually be used to
Caption: transform the business
Caption: and use design to run regular
Caption: experiments and use data to inform
Caption: strategy so
Caption: companies can innovate when they use
Caption: design and data to explore experiment
Caption: inform and de-risk right so an example
Caption: of where we've used design experiments
Caption: at hbf it was in our future state
Caption: service design work
Caption: so this is where we were able to connect
Caption: the dots between the design strategy and
Caption: the business strategy where we were able
Caption: to prove that we could get efficiency
Caption: gains and cost savings right so for
Caption: example we were able to identify that 20
Caption: of our online sales for hbf were
Caption: actually members trying to change their
Caption: level of cover
Caption: and so this informed our design strategy
Caption: where we've prototyped and experimented
Caption: with solutions for this
Caption: and then we also identified that we
Caption: could provide cost savings to hbf where
Caption: we've hypothesized that there will be
Caption: decreases in manual handling costs and
Caption: the number of calls into our cost center
Caption: and so moving forward we know that these
Caption: are also metrics that we want to measure
Caption: and spread design throughout the
Caption: business so when design works at scale
Caption: and it's embedded within the
Caption: organization it's going to have more
Caption: impact and influence
Caption: so our design practice over at hbf is
Caption: still pretty young and we're looking at
Caption: still establishing things like processes
Caption: and design standards and building out
Caption: things like our design system and these
Caption: are going to help us work at scale and
Caption: that's exactly what happens when you see
Caption: design maturity trying to build in an
Caption: organization
Caption: and so what we do start seeing we do
Caption: have signs of design culture um
Caption: throughout hbf so we're seeing things
Caption: like we've got to design an experience
Caption: chapter we've got business capabilities
Caption: that are actually aligned to our
Caption: customer journey we've got an
Caption: established research program and we've
Caption: got a guiding value proposition and
Caption: design principles and these were
Caption: actually created through things like
Caption: research concept testing
Caption: experts and employees that were
Caption: interviewed and they're our north star
Caption: for our design work
Caption: so where to next
Caption: so the design profession is still
Caption: evolving so only in the last 10 years
Caption: the last decade have we seen design as a
Caption: way to actually drive business success
Caption: and also to be used to solve for complex
Caption: human issues
Caption: so we need to make sure we still don't
Caption: lose our producers and our crafts people
Caption: these are our design specialists that
Caption: sit in those first two orders
Caption: but we need to also have our strategists
Caption: and our visionaries who work and thrive
Caption: in complexity especially in that fourth
Caption: order
Caption: and as technology continues to grow and
Caption: change so will design
Caption: so as a fun fact some people may have
Caption: spotted this uh the majority of the
Caption: images that i've used in this
Caption: presentation were actually done through
Caption: mid-journey it's an ai image generator
Caption: so things like artificial intelligence
Caption: virtual reality the metaverse and
Caption: automation are going to have huge
Caption: impacts on design in the future
Caption: and so as we're facing into a more
Caption: complex world and as it starts to change
Caption: faster than ever before designers are
Caption: well placed to help for the us all for
Caption: the big messy problem spaces that come
Caption: with this
Caption: thank you
Caption: we've got like two minutes for questions
Caption: so
Caption: getting quick all right i'll run over
Caption: quickly
Caption: awesome loved it question about the
Caption: five-point maturity model we love a
Caption: five-point maturity model for change and
Caption: agile and innovation in general does the
Caption: design maturity model that you talk to
Caption: that you guys
Caption: look at at hbf does it align with those
Caption: other maturity models and do you think
Caption: it should
Caption: we actually haven't so we haven't
Caption: actually set out a
Caption: design maturity model over at hbf
Caption: i do know that um over i'm going to use
Caption: a different reference actually so over
Caption: at asb bank in new zealand they did
Caption: actually use the envision design
Caption: maturity index to measure their own
Caption: design maturity and they actually used
Caption: it as a um
Caption: as a
Caption: like at a business level to say by next
Caption: year by the end of next financial year
Caption: we want to go from a level two to a
Caption: level three so that's where we have
Caption: actually seen it used really well there
Caption: are some different nuances as well so
Caption: the mckinsey one uh was only focused i
Caption: think it was on three different
Caption: um areas um and had only about 300
Caption: businesses that they actually
Caption: surveyed in that one
Caption: the envision one is over 2000 so it's
Caption: 2200
Caption: all over the world um all of like a
Caption: range of different industries as well
Caption: but the only the only other thing is
Caption: that they're also envisioned customers
Caption: so
Caption: everything's a little bit different and
Caption: then the nielsen normal one is also very
Caption: ux focused and it's also very subjective
Caption: as well so um like i've we had a huge
Caption: discussion a couple of weeks ago between
Caption: some of the design leads and myself and
Caption: we were like oh we're at a level two but
Caption: then there's other sections in the
Caption: business like i design strategy practice
Caption: which will probably be at level four so
Caption: it changes like you've got different
Caption: pockets in the organization so as a
Caption: whole it becomes yeah quite quite
Caption: difficult but
Caption: i think as long as there's something
Caption: there that you can actually go we think
Caption: we're roughly about this it still gives
Caption: you some good steps moving forward so
Caption: yeah
Caption: okay thank you
Caption: thanks so much sorry we're slightly over
Caption: time the next talk in here will be at 12
Caption: 20. we've got another christy christie
Caption: midag thank you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: please
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: first
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hello everyone
Caption: okay
Caption: hi on to our next talk we have uh
Caption: christy middah
Caption: who'll be speaking about from imposter
Caption: life to imposter moments tips from a
Caption: psychologist turned engineer
Caption: so a little bit about christy
Caption: she's a psychologist turned software
Caption: engineer currently navigating her way
Caption: through the world of technology
Caption: after a short but intense journey of
Caption: self-learning christie landed a job as
Caption: an associate engineer at vgw and started
Caption: passing along her knowledge as mentor at
Caption: she codes australia
Caption: six months later she got promoted to
Caption: engineer still battling impostor
Caption: feelings
Caption: she's feeling she's passionate about
Caption: helping others getting into tech solving
Caption: exciting
Caption: coding problems and cheese
Caption: okay thank you christy
Caption: thank you very much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: wow there are quite a few people in this
Caption: room
Caption: probably also a lot of you who have a
Caption: lot more experience than me
Caption: you can probably deliver way better
Caption: talks than me
Caption: i don't even know why everybody's either
Caption: listening to me in the first place
Caption: i feel like such a fraud
Caption: i don't see any slides up at the moment
Caption: so i'm just gonna keep going
Caption: so can i get a hands up if anyone has
Caption: ever felt kind of similar like you feel
Caption: like you don't really belong that you
Caption: don't deserve your success
Caption: oh that's good that's pretty much
Caption: everyone here
Caption: nice that makes me feel better
Caption: um so yeah for those of you who came in
Caption: late and missed the introduction my name
Caption: is christy i am a psychologist who is
Caption: now currently a software engineer and
Caption: i'm going to talk about
Caption: my journey into tech and kind of
Caption: navigating this whole new world feeling
Caption: like an imposter
Caption: and while i'm
Caption: talking i'm also going to share a lot of
Caption: my personal experiences which i'm a
Caption: little bit nervous about but i do feel
Caption: that
Caption: sharing and
Caption: normalizing and acknowledging these
Caption: feelings go a long way to actually
Caption: overcoming them
Caption: it might be wonderfully try one of the
Caption: different
Caption: outfits
Caption: sorry a little bit of a technical
Caption: malfunction here
Caption: yeah i just tried a different
Caption: one
Caption: that's looking much better
Caption: cool
Caption: so now you missed my really cool gif of
Caption: putting a hand out but that's all right
Caption: because everybody else put their hand up
Caption: so that's cool
Caption: so i want to give a big shout out to all
Caption: the sponsors because without them
Caption: you and i or wouldn't have been here
Caption: today and this event wouldn't have been
Caption: possible so thank you very much to all
Caption: of the sponsors
Caption: all right
Caption: so i'm going to start off with one of my
Caption: personal stories
Caption: when i started joining the tech industry
Caption: i felt quite overwhelmed
Caption: when i just like my first day there was
Caption: a lot of new things to learn there was
Caption: new languages to learn a new code base
Caption: to navigate all these new tools that i
Caption: had to learn about
Caption: and it was quite frankly a little bit
Caption: much and especially also looking at my
Caption: colleagues who all seemed to navigate
Caption: this really really well
Caption: more often than not i kind of felt like
Caption: do i even belong in this industry
Caption: maybe i shouldn't have done this
Caption: so what i felt and i'm still currently
Caption: regularly experiencing is the textbook
Caption: definition of imposter syndrome
Caption: and imposter syndrome can be defined as
Caption: feelings of self-doubt and personal
Caption: incompetence that persists despite your
Caption: education experience or accomplishments
Caption: so you might wonder what does it feel
Caption: like to have imposter feelings
Caption: well if you kind of feel like you are
Caption: big birds trying to fit in with the
Caption: death vader darth vader grew on the
Caption: death star that's when you can probably
Caption: tell that you have impossible feelings
Caption: but jokes aside there are some common
Caption: imposter thoughts that are likely to
Caption: occur
Caption: so let's have a look and see what goes
Caption: on in the mind of people with impossible
Caption: feelings
Caption: so you might feel like you are a fake
Caption: and you're going to be found out
Caption: sorry about that
Caption: you might feel that you actually don't
Caption: deserve your success and you may have
Caption: just gotten lucky
Caption: you may feel like um you're not really
Caption: that special at all and you feel like if
Caption: you can do it everybody else can do it
Caption: or
Caption: you may not be very good with praise and
Caption: just kind of like wave it off as like oh
Caption: i had a lot of help
Caption: or maybe you just think that they were
Caption: just being nice to you
Caption: but regardless what you're feeling it
Caption: turns out to be
Caption: very very common
Caption: within the tech industry it's actually
Caption: 58 of people who experience
Caption: imposter feelings currently in their
Caption: career and this includes people from
Caption: companies like amazon google and
Caption: facebook
Caption: so this is a study that has been done by
Caption: blind they have done a very very
Caption: scientific study where they send people
Caption: a question in their app and ask do you
Caption: have impulsive feelings yes or no
Caption: i mean
Caption: it's very simple but
Caption: yeah as you can see they they are
Caption: interviewed a lot of people in a lot of
Caption: different companies that are quite
Caption: familiar to most of you i reckon
Caption: and this is a graph of
Caption: these companies that have the highest
Caption: rates of imposter feelings
Caption: so
Caption: rest assured you are not alone
Caption: but why is it such a common thing in
Caption: tech why do so many people in our
Caption: industry feel like they're undeserving
Caption: of their success despite their obvious
Caption: merit
Caption: well i can think of one thing
Caption: i don't know if anyone here has ever
Caption: tried to explain to their mom what it is
Caption: that they're doing without them zoning
Caption: out or kind of looking at you like
Caption: you're speaking in another language
Caption: but it's not just the people from
Caption: outside the industry it kind of like
Caption: happens within the industry as well i'm
Caption: sure a lot of you have heard stories of
Caption: projects that have been pushed where you
Caption: like gave an estimate that it would take
Caption: four weeks six weeks and they would push
Caption: you to do it in four weeks
Caption: but then there's also
Caption: expectations that come from within so
Caption: for instance if you're a new starter in
Caption: the industry you may not really know
Caption: what you need to do in order to perform
Caption: in your industry
Caption: or if you are more experienced something
Caption: like a promotion or new responsibilities
Caption: can trigger impulsive feelings as well
Caption: then there is also the fast pace that's
Caption: happening in the tech industry things
Caption: change a lot
Caption: there's new languages all the time
Caption: there's new
Caption: concepts that you need to learn all the
Caption: time you have to keep up otherwise you
Caption: will be outdated
Caption: and the same kind of works for companies
Caption: in general you always have to try and do
Caption: the new thing to make your customers
Caption: happy otherwise they will go elsewhere
Caption: and it also kind of happens to yourself
Caption: you just want to keep up you want to do
Caption: a good job as a new starter you might
Caption: even want to like rush into things and
Caption: make sure that you get up to speed as
Caption: soon as possible
Caption: and in the process you may end up being
Caption: burned out
Caption: um but we shouldn't talk about it right
Caption: because it's kind of embarrassing to
Caption: have these feelings and i'm probably the
Caption: only person who has it
Caption: no splash you aren't
Caption: and then there's also the uh part of
Caption: like some of us
Caption: this has literally happened to me today
Caption: i haven't had a single line it was
Caption: great um
Caption: yeah so one of the other things that can
Caption: cause impulsive feelings as well is
Caption: especially from people from
Caption: underrepresented groups is that they
Caption: don't really have these people that they
Caption: can look up to they miss um
Caption: people with empathetic leadership skills
Caption: or
Caption: like just generally people who look like
Caption: them who've had success in their
Caption: workplace
Caption: and if things weren't already bad enough
Caption: in the tech industry
Caption: of course we also have been hit by this
Caption: thing called covet
Caption: and covert has kind of made us work in
Caption: in different ways now we all have kind
Caption: of a new role and we have to get ready
Caption: like have to be ready to work from home
Caption: and some of you may have even been
Caption: parenting as well while i'm teaching
Caption: while working from home
Caption: so yeah lots have happened and lots of
Caption: things that can actually trigger your
Caption: impulsive feelings
Caption: but despite what you're feeling
Caption: is can be quite nerve-wracking it's
Caption: actually pretty normal and having a
Caption: little bit of self-doubt is actually
Caption: healthy because it will push you to do
Caption: better things to become better to learn
Caption: new things
Caption: so you shouldn't feel bad about it
Caption: the goal here is to not feel like an
Caption: imposter ever again but to have the
Caption: tools to talk yourself down faster when
Caption: you have an imposter moment
Caption: so let's go back to those expectations
Caption: i'm sure many of you have seen this one
Caption: when i got promoted about six months ago
Caption: i felt like i didn't deserve it at all i
Caption: wasn't ready i still felt like i had so
Caption: much to learn and there were so many
Caption: other associates who were way more
Caption: prepared for this than me
Caption: so yeah my expectations of where i
Caption: needed to be were
Caption: where i thought i had to be versus where
Caption: i actually had to be way out of whack
Caption: because if i look at it rationally i had
Caption: met all those requirements
Caption: um
Caption: yeah so
Caption: well sorry kind of blanking here
Caption: yeah so i focused so hard on the things
Caption: that i didn't know that i kind of forget
Caption: how far i actually have come so far
Caption: um if you look at me a year and a half
Caption: ago the only thing i was probably able
Caption: to do was write a line of python that
Caption: said hello world in a console
Caption: and now i am working as a software
Caption: engineer full-time at a company i am
Caption: mentoring and guiding people who are new
Caption: to the industry or new to the job and i
Caption: am standing here presenting for all of
Caption: you so that should probably count for
Caption: something i guess
Caption: you're making me shy
Caption: um
Caption: so yeah appreciate the progress that you
Caption: have made so far
Caption: but if you're really struggling to do
Caption: that
Caption: there's other ways that you can kind of
Caption: like
Caption: uh focus on how far you've come and
Caption: that's mentoring others
Caption: if you are able to teach a new concept
Caption: to a person who's like just starting out
Caption: that's a really good way to sort of
Caption: gauge like oh i've actually managed to
Caption: learn this myself quite well and i'm
Caption: able to actually
Caption: teach this to other people
Caption: but if you are really really set on
Caption: looking forward
Caption: please remember that your career is a
Caption: marathon and not a sprint
Caption: if you take a nice steady pace like a
Caption: marathon runner you can learn all these
Caption: new skills and learn all this new
Caption: knowledge
Caption: while
Caption: not really zooming past anything that's
Caption: important
Caption: and part of that is also to do with
Caption: setting appropriate goals
Caption: you want to be able to
Caption: focus on the core skills developing
Caption: growth skills and rather than focusing
Caption: on trying to learn everything all at
Caption: once which i'm sure is a rabbit hole
Caption: that many of us have fallen into let me
Caption: include it
Caption: and also stop comparing yourself to
Caption: others this is one that's very easy to
Caption: fall into as well
Caption: you tend to kind of forget that other
Caption: people may have had like a lot more
Caption: experience than you
Caption: um
Caption: so comparing yourself to someone else
Caption: who went through a way different journey
Caption: or has been working in the industry for
Caption: a few years now doesn't really help
Caption: so instead try and look at them like
Caption: role models
Caption: or turn to them for help
Caption: so it can really be helpful to share
Caption: your imposter feelings with others
Caption: because
Caption: they will a lot of them will be able to
Caption: kind of like acknowledge that they're
Caption: probably experiencing the same thing
Caption: from time to time or have experiences in
Caption: the past
Caption: um and having these feelings of
Caption: knowledge can work quite well i can tell
Caption: you from experience
Caption: because um i share my feelings with my
Caption: manager
Caption: all the time
Caption: i can't i can't even count the number of
Caption: times that i've been in a one-on-one
Caption: being like i feel like i'm not
Caption: progressing fast enough and i need to
Caption: know more and i need to learn more and
Caption: he's just always managed to make me feel
Caption: better and that's because he has like
Caption: all of this experience and knowledge of
Caption: like yeah he has experienced the same
Caption: kind of feelings and he has seen similar
Caption: things by mentoring others as well so
Caption: it's incredibly helpful to have a mentor
Caption: to help you out with this sort of stuff
Caption: but you now might also be wondering
Caption: kristy weren't you a psychologist
Caption: you should probably have some cool
Caption: tricks up your sleeve right
Caption: i do
Caption: okay but i want to give a little bit of
Caption: a disclaimer here
Caption: because as a psychologist we are really
Caption: good at
Caption: advising other people and helping
Caption: guiding other people but when it comes
Caption: to ourselves those rules all of a sudden
Caption: don't seem to apply anymore
Caption: which is why i'm still having impulsive
Caption: feelings
Caption: but there are specifically two exercises
Caption: that i wanted to share with you all that
Caption: have been really helpful for myself but
Caption: also
Caption: clients that i have treated in the past
Caption: with similar issues and these are
Caption: exercises that are part of cognitive
Caption: behavioral therapy and i will really do
Caption: a deep dive into that because i could do
Caption: a whole different talk about that but i
Caption: will give a brief overview of these
Caption: exercises
Caption: and
Caption: i have added a qr code for you to scan
Caption: so you can find some worksheets related
Caption: to them as well and you can look it up
Caption: yourself
Caption: so the first one is cognitive
Caption: restructuring
Caption: oh everybody's putting up their phone
Caption: that's cool
Caption: and cognitive restructuring is a way to
Caption: really get to the root of why you are
Caption: having this imposter feeling in the
Caption: first place and how you came to believe
Caption: them
Caption: so you're kind of using this technique
Caption: called socratic questioning where you
Caption: just challenge the thought that you're
Caption: having at the moment you might ask
Caption: yourself questions like
Caption: is this thought based on emotions or
Caption: facts
Caption: do i can i think of any facts that
Caption: actually support this thought that i'm
Caption: having or can i think of any facts that
Caption: um support the fact that i that it's not
Caption: true what i'm thinking
Caption: and it's those kinds of questions that
Caption: will help you um kind of like
Caption: get to the bottom of this in a slightly
Caption: more objective way which has been quite
Caption: helpful for me
Caption: and the next exercise is called
Caption: dysfunctional thought record
Caption: uh it's the same qr code by the way so
Caption: you don't have to scan it again if you
Caption: already have it
Caption: um this functional thought record really
Caption: helps you find out what triggers your
Caption: imposter thought
Caption: it asks you uh to write down things like
Caption: the time and date of your thought what
Caption: the thought is how you would rate its
Caption: intensity and emotions that come with it
Caption: but the most important part of this one
Caption: is that you think of alternative
Caption: thoughts that could actually be more
Caption: positive or helpful to replace your
Caption: negative one
Caption: well now so far i have been giving you a
Caption: lot of tips to handle impossible
Caption: feelings by yourself and this is
Caption: probably a lot of the stuff that you can
Caption: find online as well
Caption: but one of the things that i find
Caption: is really important here is that
Caption: leadership can actually have an
Caption: important role in helping other people
Caption: with impulsive feelings too
Caption: and so leaders why should you help out
Caption: others with imposter feelings because it
Caption: actually turns out in research that
Caption: imposter feelings
Caption: impact the performance of both the
Caption: individual and the team
Caption: it's actually correlated with job poor
Caption: job performance for job satisfaction and
Caption: burnout
Caption: so it's important to learn and to
Caption: identify impulsive feelings in others
Caption: i need a little bit of help with this
Caption: one
Caption: so impossible feelings can be quite
Caption: complex and sometimes not even that
Caption: obvious your team member may seem
Caption: fatigued or disinterested or
Caption: maybe just completely the opposite and
Caption: really on top of things and and going
Caption: beyond
Caption: above and beyond to try and just do the
Caption: right thing and
Caption: so that they can prove their worth
Caption: but what about the high performer who
Caption: tends to avoid these like more tricky
Caption: projects
Caption: or the person who doesn't put their hand
Caption: up for a promotion
Caption: or the person who
Caption: look seems to be uncomfortable with
Caption: praise and kind of just like waves it
Caption: off as
Caption: luck or
Caption: something that they got a lot of help
Caption: from other people
Caption: or maybe they just appear really
Caption: skeptical when you encourage them to do
Caption: something new
Caption: you also want to stay attuned to
Caption: negative self-talk
Caption: things like a silly question
Caption: or
Caption: i did really terrible on that
Caption: presentation
Caption: um
Caption: or
Caption: someone could probably someone better
Caption: should probably be doing this or someone
Caption: else should probably be doing this are a
Caption: really good examples of self-deprecating
Caption: talk
Caption: and can be harmful for a team member's
Caption: performance as well
Caption: but to be fair it can be pretty hard to
Caption: walk up to a manager and talk about
Caption: these kinds of feelings right
Caption: so as a manager you want to be if you
Caption: want to be able to have these kinds of
Caption: conversations you want to show empathy
Caption: and vulnerability and that means that
Caption: you might have to open up about your
Caption: imposter feelings first before someone
Caption: else feels comfortable enough to come to
Caption: you
Caption: so when a team member does come to you
Caption: it's important that you acknowledge
Caption: their feelings and maybe share one of
Caption: your own experiences oh i need to wrap
Caption: this up apparently
Caption: quick quick you want to organize
Caption: appropriate mentoring
Caption: and this doesn't necessarily have to be
Caption: a senior person this can be anyone on
Caption: your team who maybe have slightly more
Caption: experience than
Caption: the person who's just joining
Caption: you want to get feedback from team
Caption: members about the work environment so
Caption: one thing that my new vp of engineering
Caption: recently did was just have a chat with
Caption: all of us and ask questions like
Caption: um what do i do when you're grumpy
Caption: should i just come up to you leave you
Caption: alone send you a message how do you like
Caption: to
Caption: to get praised do you like that
Caption: one-on-one am i is it okay if i share
Caption: this stuff in a team things like that
Caption: can all go a long way to make a person
Caption: more comfortable with these sort of
Caption: situations
Caption: and you want to of course give praise to
Caption: and celebrate wins with your entire team
Caption: in the way that they all feel
Caption: comfortable with
Caption: so quick recap
Caption: impulsive feelings and dealing with them
Caption: can be quite hard
Caption: but if you can acknowledge them that is
Caption: the first step towards actually um
Caption: dealing with them and over time you'll
Caption: notice that your
Caption: moments will last
Caption: will be shorter and shorter and you'll
Caption: have less and less of them
Caption: you could do things like managing
Caption: all these things that i just previously
Caption: mentioned that's what you can do
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: but i do really wanted to say this
Caption: before i step off stage and give it to
Caption: someone else it is okay to ask for
Caption: professional help as well dealing with
Caption: imposter syndrome can be hard and to be
Caption: honest i have actually have seen a
Caption: counselor myself to deal with some
Caption: similar kind of issues and i found that
Caption: it's been really really helpful for me
Caption: well thank you unfortunately i can't
Caption: take any questions but feel free to come
Caption: up to me after the talk or reach out on
Caption: linkedin
Caption: thank you all so much for listening
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you christy despite the imposter
Caption: syndrome you did amazing
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is office nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: let's go
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are to love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: before lunch um this one is by melissa
Caption: houghton
Caption: and it's called leadership through
Caption: self-awareness
Caption: so a little bit about melissa melissa
Caption: houghton is a lead software engineer at
Caption: aznix and a microsoft mvp in developer
Caption: technologies
Caption: her work is focused on application
Caption: development using angular.net and azure
Caption: but she has a wide variety of skills and
Caption: is always open to learning new things
Caption: an advocate for women in tech with a
Caption: passion for leadership technology and
Caption: giving back to the community
Caption: she frequently frequents tech events is
Caption: an international conference speaker and
Caption: organizer of ddd melbourne conference
Caption: melb.net meetup and microsoft au new
Caption: breakpoint community
Caption: originally from california melissa loves
Caption: to travel and now lives in melbourne
Caption: australia
Caption: thanks melissa
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: become a great leader by understanding
Caption: yourself
Caption: a leader is not determined by someone's
Caption: title but by their influence over others
Caption: and the people around them
Caption: anyone can be a leader but first you
Caption: need to have the right skills
Caption: and a key skill to becoming a great
Caption: leader is understanding ourself
Caption: so through this talk i will dive into
Caption: leadership through self-awareness and
Caption: how building up your skills in
Caption: self-awareness can help you become a
Caption: better leader
Caption: because a leader is not just
Caption: somebody who's out at the front it's
Caption: somebody who has followers
Caption: and through self-awareness not only will
Caption: you become a better leader but so will
Caption: those around you and so will your
Caption: organization and your team
Caption: so first i'd like to give a big shout
Caption: out to all of the the organizers for ddd
Caption: perth i used to live here in perth
Caption: myself and helped organize dvd for a
Caption: couple years over in perth and now i
Caption: help with one in melbourne and there's a
Caption: ton of work that goes into an event like
Caption: this and also a massive shout out to all
Caption: of our sponsors because without them
Caption: this wouldn't be able to happen
Caption: so as i mentioned my name is melissa
Caption: houghton and i'm a lead software
Caption: engineer and also now developer
Caption: relations at azenics and xenix is part
Caption: of mantle group who are one of the
Caption: sponsors here today
Caption: i'm also a microsoft mvp in developer
Caption: technologies
Caption: i try to be pretty active on twitter and
Caption: if you are on twitter please follow me
Caption: and take photos of my talk today and
Caption: share along your thoughts as i'm going
Caption: so this talk is all about leadership
Caption: through self-awareness and that concept
Caption: is not a unique one
Caption: and i got the idea for this talk through
Caption: all the different leadership training
Caption: courses i've done and i also did a lot
Caption: of research on the topic there's tons of
Caption: studies that have been published about
Caption: this but really the idea for the talk
Caption: came through a leadership camp that i
Caption: attended
Caption: through rotary club and then i went on
Caption: to be a camp counselor for
Caption: this camp was called ryla which stands
Caption: for rotary youth leadership awards and
Caption: the whole camp was centered around
Caption: building up your self-awareness and how
Caption: that can help you to become a better
Caption: leader
Caption: so i was
Caption: in this camp is also focused on young
Caption: adults age 18 to 28. so i was lucky
Caption: enough to be able to attend a few years
Caption: ago and then go on to council and help
Caption: share those skills with other people as
Caption: well
Caption: and i'm not trying to retrofit the camp
Caption: into this talk but that idea of becoming
Caption: a great leader by understanding yourself
Caption: is one that has always stuck with me so
Caption: i decided to put together this talk for
Caption: all of you
Caption: so what is leadership leadership has
Caption: many definitions
Caption: i looked up the definition and it says
Caption: it's the action of leading a group of
Caption: people or an organization
Caption: i didn't find that entirely helpful so i
Caption: went on to then look up the definition
Caption: of fleet
Caption: and this said it's the initiative in an
Caption: action an example for others to follow
Caption: it so if we put that together we can say
Caption: that leadership is the action of taking
Caption: the initiative
Caption: and setting an example for other people
Caption: to then follow
Caption: and i like this definition
Caption: because to me a leader is somebody who
Caption: has followers
Caption: the followers are what make you a leader
Caption: it's not someone who necessarily has it
Caption: in their title or is that at the top of
Caption: the ladder in a corporate organization
Caption: it's the person who is out there making
Caption: a difference who is checking on those
Caption: teammates who might be struggling a
Caption: little bit having support being a role
Caption: model and setting an example really
Caption: being a true influence for others around
Caption: them
Caption: they can be anyone at any level they can
Caption: have any sort of type of background
Caption: personality be any type of person they
Caption: could be you
Caption: a leader is someone who
Caption: is out at the front being the center for
Caption: everyone else to see how they can
Caption: really truly be a great leader in
Caption: helping other people around them be the
Caption: best versions of themselves
Caption: and with the right skills and attitudes
Caption: and approach to working with others
Caption: people will naturally follow you
Caption: so what makes a good leader i'd like to
Caption: hear from some people in the audience
Caption: what do you think makes a good leader
Caption: just shout it out
Caption: any thoughts
Caption: empathy yeah that's a great one
Caption: trust yes
Caption: respect definitely
Caption: listening yes
Caption: understanding yeah
Caption: yeah all of these traits are definitely
Caption: things that we really want to see in
Caption: leaders we
Caption: want to be able to have them empathize
Caption: with us listen to our concerns to really
Caption: support us as we're doing things and
Caption: understand when we're going through
Caption: maybe difficult situations
Caption: so they're the people who are you know
Caption: supporting us through those processes um
Caption: helping us when there might be maybe
Caption: there's little tasks on the side that
Caption: may have been forgotten to help the team
Caption: reach the goal
Caption: and it doesn't always have to be just
Caption: one leader a lot of situations there's
Caption: leaders in different aspects that all
Caption: work together to help the team
Caption: achieve the end goal
Caption: think about in a game of basketball you
Caption: have the coach
Caption: you might have the team captain or you
Caption: have someone who's setting up the play
Caption: who's making the assist and then the
Caption: person who's shooting the hoop in the
Caption: end
Caption: all of them
Caption: had their own part to play in reaching
Caption: that outcome and they're all leaders in
Caption: their own right they took that
Caption: initiative and they supported one
Caption: another to help achieve success
Caption: so in the words of bill gates
Caption: as we look ahead into the next century
Caption: leaders will be those who empower others
Caption: so how do we empower others
Caption: how do we become that person that other
Caption: people want to follow
Caption: and it really can come down to
Caption: understanding of ourselves
Caption: before we can look at taking care of
Caption: those around us and really influencing
Caption: them we first have to understand
Caption: ourselves and our own actions and how we
Caption: approach different situations
Caption: self-awareness does not equate to
Caption: leadership but it is a fundamental skill
Caption: that can really help you to be a great
Caption: leader
Caption: and all those traits that we mentioned
Caption: empathy listening active communication
Caption: being authentic and supporting those
Caption: around you really empowering others
Caption: it first starts with understanding
Caption: yourself
Caption: so self-awareness well this is the
Caption: act of being aware of yourself
Caption: it's all about being aware of your
Caption: emotions
Caption: your personality how you react in
Caption: different situations and how all those
Caption: things are perceived by others your
Caption: strengths and weaknesses the skills that
Caption: you have that you need to continue to to
Caption: work on are the ones that you're really
Caption: great at and you can really harness and
Caption: use
Caption: people are not born completely
Caption: self-aware but as an infant as a baby we
Caption: do start to develop self-awareness and
Caption: we can continue to build it throughout
Caption: our life
Caption: however research has shown that only 10
Caption: to 15 percent of people are what they
Caption: consider truly self-aware
Caption: well we can all work on our
Caption: self-awareness and continue to build it
Caption: the study of self-awareness that we know
Caption: it today
Caption: began in 1972 with shelley duvall and
Caption: robert wookland
Caption: although the concept of self-awareness
Caption: is one that has been around for
Caption: centuries and people have been talking
Caption: and trying to understand self for a very
Caption: long time
Caption: with that theory from shelley duvall and
Caption: robert wicklund proposed that at a given
Caption: moment
Caption: people can focus attention on their self
Caption: or on the external environment around
Caption: them
Caption: and through their research they divided
Caption: self-awareness into two sub-categories
Caption: the first is your internal
Caption: self-awareness so this is the awareness
Caption: of your internal state of being and how
Caption: you are your emotions and how you're
Caption: reacting to things your natural
Caption: tendencies and generally we don't always
Caption: focus internally or on ourselves but
Caption: there's certain situations that can
Caption: cause our attention to be drawn inward
Caption: take for a moment to take a deep breath
Caption: breathe into your nose and out through
Caption: your mouth
Caption: most of the time you don't really think
Caption: about how you're breathing but because i
Caption: drew your attention to it and you
Caption: actively took that deep breath in and
Caption: out you have become aware of your
Caption: breathing so internal self-awareness is
Caption: something that happens privately
Caption: something inside our head of okay this
Caption: is now how we're breathing in and out
Caption: it's the type of awareness when you
Caption: become aware of some aspect of yourself
Caption: but in a way that no one else can see
Caption: because it's happening inside your mind
Caption: so it's an awareness of that internal
Caption: state
Caption: on the other hand is the external
Caption: self-awareness
Caption: and what this means is it's really our
Caption: perceived awareness
Caption: of how others see us and it's only
Caption: perceived because we don't actually 100
Caption: know what other people are seeing in us
Caption: but we usually have some sort of idea or
Caption: maybe just a guess of what people are
Caption: seeing when maybe they're watching us up
Caption: on stage or we're interacting with them
Caption: in certain situation
Caption: for example here i am up here talking
Caption: and i can see you all looking at me and
Caption: i'm coming to some conclusions of what
Caption: you might be thinking
Caption: when we know that we're being watched
Caption: and evaluated we often try to act in
Caption: ways that we think are socially
Caption: acceptable
Caption: so you're in a situation with your
Caption: friends and someone says a joke that
Caption: might be a bit controversial
Caption: you'll probably look around your friends
Caption: to see how they react before you react
Caption: as well so you want to make sure you fit
Caption: into those societal norms
Caption: and that's an example of that external
Caption: self-awareness
Caption: so our external self-awareness is
Caption: usually influences or actions to be
Caption: related to society expectations
Caption: where our internal self-awareness is
Caption: really driven by our personal values and
Caption: the things that really mean most to us
Caption: internally
Caption: so dr tasha urge
Caption: research self-awareness in the context
Caption: of leaders and organizations and took
Caption: the concept of these internal and
Caption: external and categorized it into four
Caption: separate
Caption: sub-archetypes of self-awareness
Caption: so on the bottom left corner we have
Caption: what are called seekers these people
Caption: have
Caption: the
Caption: low internal and low external so they
Caption: don't really know too much about
Caption: themselves but they're open-minded and
Caption: they're they're
Caption: open to
Caption: learning new things however they
Caption: probably are getting frustrated because
Caption: they're not quite sure what they value
Caption: and they might not understand what might
Caption: be happening in certain situations
Caption: next we have on the top left corner
Caption: those who have high internal and low
Caption: external
Caption: so these people are very clear on what
Caption: is really most important to them but
Caption: they might not be as aware of how their
Caption: actions and things that they're doing
Caption: are perceived by others and often
Caption: they're a bit close-minded and not open
Caption: to learning new things so that can harm
Caption: some of their relationships with people
Caption: in the bottom right corner we have
Caption: pleasers
Caption: these people are very highly externally
Caption: self-aware very aware of how other
Caption: people are perceiving them
Caption: but they're have low internal
Caption: self-awareness so they're not as
Caption: connected with what is imp important to
Caption: them and can feel frustrated and that
Caption: can hold them back from getting success
Caption: and fulfillment out of what they're
Caption: doing
Caption: and in the top right corner we have
Caption: those 10 to 15 percent of people who are
Caption: truly self-aware
Caption: they have the high internal and high
Caption: external they really know
Caption: they're really in touch with who they
Caption: are and what they really value but
Caption: they're also very aware of those around
Caption: them and they're aware how they can
Caption: adapt to those current situations
Caption: now it's all the scale and a lot of it
Caption: depends on the situation all that but we
Caption: can work on building our different parts
Caption: of our self-awareness
Caption: so if we're looking though some of those
Caption: things that we're talking about the
Caption: self-awareness can be negative so if
Caption: we're focusing on the wrong things if
Caption: we're focusing term too much internally
Caption: we become maybe a bit self-obsessed or
Caption: you have trouble understanding you know
Caption: challenging situations or
Caption: things that might be out of the norm for
Caption: us
Caption: or if we're focusing too much externally
Caption: we can become quite anxious and
Caption: always aware of things that other people
Caption: are judging us or things that are
Caption: negatively happening
Caption: so we have to be careful with our our
Caption: management of self-awareness there's
Caption: something that's called the sadder but
Caption: wiser paradox it says the more we learn
Caption: about ourselves it not only makes us
Caption: wiser but it can also make us sadder
Caption: so we need to change how we address the
Caption: self-awareness and make sure we're not
Caption: mulling over the negative emotions and
Caption: instead reflecting objectively on the
Caption: positives
Caption: and we can do this by looking at the
Caption: questions that we're asking ourselves
Caption: we need to make sure our introspection
Caption: is on that positive side because if we
Caption: just start reflecting without the right
Caption: context it doesn't necessarily make us
Caption: happy it can make us worse because we're
Caption: focusing on the wrong things
Caption: and research has shown that we're not
Caption: able to pull up all of our unconscious
Caption: thoughts feelings and emotions
Caption: and as you learned in the chemo keynote
Caption: this morning as well your memory can be
Caption: wrong you can if you're looking at
Caption: something in a negative context when
Caption: you're remembering it you can end up
Caption: having these negative emotions connected
Caption: to it
Caption: so we need to focus on moving forward
Caption: and instead of fixating on what happens
Caption: and we can do this by changing the
Caption: questions that we ask ourselves instead
Caption: of asking why we need to ask what
Caption: instead of saying why me why did this
Caption: happen
Caption: look at what can i do to make it better
Caption: what can i change what can i learn from
Caption: this situation
Caption: instead of asking
Caption: why am i so upset look at what can make
Caption: me happy what can i do to change this
Caption: situation focusing on becoming that
Caption: aware archetype working on both the
Caption: internal and external awareness looking
Caption: at what we're doing what we're feeling
Caption: and what our blind spots of what we
Caption: might not be aware be
Caption: and there's different tools that can
Caption: help us do this one of them is what's
Caption: called the jahari window
Caption: so this is an activity
Caption: where you get a list of adjectives that
Caption: describe a person
Caption: so it can be something like cheerful
Caption: excited maybe reserved something like
Caption: that and
Caption: you and a friend go through the list and
Caption: you circle all the adjectives that you
Caption: think describe yourself and your friends
Caption: circles adjectives that they think
Caption: describes you
Caption: you then compare the two lists and the
Caption: adjectives that you both circle are part
Caption: of your external self so this is the
Caption: things that you're reflecting to others
Caption: that they're aware of
Caption: the things that only you circled is
Caption: that's your internal self things that
Caption: you find
Caption: you are part of you but maybe other
Caption: people don't see that then your blind
Caption: spots are things that other people see
Caption: in you but you don't necessarily see in
Caption: yourself so there's a few different
Caption: tools and techniques that you can do to
Caption: help you build up these skills
Caption: and if we continue to do that reflection
Caption: we can get the positives out of
Caption: self-awareness
Caption: we can change those questions from why
Caption: to what
Caption: and get an increased understanding of
Caption: our self-development needs and the
Caption: things that we need to work on
Caption: and that around us can help us become
Caption: more proactive at work more
Caption: understanding of others more open-minded
Caption: and willing to take on the initiative
Caption: and be able to
Caption: do well in challenging situations or
Caption: when faced with adversity
Caption: it can make us become more successful
Caption: and have more satisfied employees and
Caption: teammates around us and it can even lead
Caption: to organizations becoming more
Caption: successful and profitable as well
Caption: so to develop these self-awareness
Caption: skills
Caption: there's other tools such as
Caption: understanding our internal self and our
Caption: personality
Caption: so our personality is usually determined
Caption: by our genetics but also environments
Caption: and situations and in how we're erased
Caption: and it's the characteristic patterns of
Caption: like how we think and behave and act in
Caption: certain situations and there's many
Caption: different tools that can help us to
Caption: understand a bit more about our
Caption: personality
Caption: a lot of these might not be 100 correct
Caption: and it might be influenced by the
Caption: situation in which you took the test but
Caption: it can help guide you to understand
Caption: yourself a little bit more
Caption: so one that i've taken in the past that
Caption: i found was useful was called the disk
Caption: theory so this separates your
Caption: personality into fortrate and you get a
Caption: report
Caption: that shows how you might act in certain
Caption: situations whether that's when there's a
Caption: conflict arising or you're faced with a
Caption: challenge or you're doing something you
Caption: really enjoy
Caption: it breaks it down into four categories
Caption: first is
Caption: more dominant which is someone who's
Caption: more results-oriented strong-willed or
Caption: often direct
Caption: next is the influence being more
Caption: optimistic lively enthusiastic
Caption: then steadiness which is even tempered
Caption: patient and tactful
Caption: and then conscious
Caption: i have trouble saying that word a bit
Caption: more analytical and semantic as well
Caption: and it's looking at really how you
Caption: prefer to focus in on the world how you
Caption: process information and react in
Caption: different scenarios
Caption: and these frameworks really just give
Caption: you a better understanding of yourself
Caption: but can also help you understand those
Caption: around you so if you do these tests
Caption: with some of your team members and then
Caption: compare the results it can really help
Caption: you to understand how you can work
Caption: better together
Caption: i had a situation where i had a
Caption: colleague who was in a similar position
Caption: of mine and we're often working together
Caption: but constantly butting heads
Caption: i had a hard time communicating with her
Caption: and really just you know underst
Caption: difficulty understanding her approach to
Caption: different situations
Caption: but we took this test and compared our
Caption: results and she was super high on the d
Caption: side the d and c side and i was really
Caption: high on the s and i side so completely
Caption: opposite scales
Caption: of the spectrum
Caption: but because of this i was able to
Caption: understand her a little bit better and
Caption: that allowed me to then adjust my
Caption: approach when i was working with her and
Caption: understand a bit more when she was
Caption: communicating with me in a way that i
Caption: naturally did not enjoy as much so
Caption: helped us work better together in the
Caption: end
Caption: along with understanding our personality
Caption: type we can help to understand our
Caption: leadership styles and look at developing
Caption: different types of leadership styles and
Caption: adjusting them depending on our
Caption: situation with our organization
Caption: this is called the
Caption: full
Caption: range leadership model and it's really
Caption: dividing into
Caption: uh four or three types one that's split
Caption: across two subcategories and the first
Caption: leadership type is what's called the
Caption: laissez-faire and this is really giving
Caption: the empowerment to your team members and
Caption: those around you this is letting them
Caption: make the decisions and really empowering
Caption: them so it's the the least sort of
Caption: hands-on and it's really good if your
Caption: team is really highly skilled and highly
Caption: experienced and trustworthy to reach
Caption: that goal really empowering them to be
Caption: the leaders themselves
Caption: the next is the transactional leadership
Caption: which is more about motivating through
Caption: a system of rewards and and maybe
Caption: punishments um
Caption: and that's broken into categories of
Caption: where management only steps in
Caption: if the team isn't doing well otherwise
Caption: lets them keep going and giving them
Caption: rewards and the other is focused on that
Caption: reward
Caption: of the objectives
Caption: this is good if your organization
Caption: is uh really wanting to standardize
Caption: practices and developing on a journey of
Caption: becoming a highly effective uh operating
Caption: team
Caption: and it yeah it's helpful it helps for
Caption: standardizing those practices the the
Caption: last
Caption: type is the transformational leadership
Caption: this is about really being that
Caption: inspirational motivation
Caption: visionary role model that people look
Caption: for and it's been proven to be the most
Caption: effective
Caption: it has more of a humanitarian approach
Caption: and is really underpinned by
Caption: self-awareness as well
Caption: so
Caption: these different types
Caption: you can have different styles and you
Caption: can also adapt and change your style
Caption: it's important to get an understanding
Caption: of how do you like to lead others
Caption: we can also look to develop our
Caption: leadership skills such as communication
Caption: research has found that communication is
Caption: central to leadership
Caption: internal communication in an
Caption: organization can significantly
Caption: increase
Caption: a someone's your team's productivity
Caption: and there is also a
Caption: theory that communication in a message
Caption: is seven percent
Caption: verbal
Caption: 38 tone in expression and 55
Caption: body language
Caption: so there is a bit of a debate on the
Caption: exact percentages that everything goes
Caption: across but there's a general
Caption: understanding that 70 to 90
Caption: of communication is non-verbal
Caption: so that means it's really important for
Caption: us to think about how we're delivering
Caption: messages to our teammates are you just
Caption: sending an email with an important team
Caption: update or are you putting out a video or
Caption: maybe jumping on a video call and a chat
Caption: think about how you like to be
Caption: communicated to as well
Caption: do you like to have all of the
Caption: information up front before a meeting or
Caption: do you like to just have a short quick
Caption: summary and understand that and
Caption: communicate it back to your team which
Caption: means they will in turn work better with
Caption: you
Caption: especially now that we're in you know
Caption: pretty much
Caption: a lot of remote based working situations
Caption: that communication is very important and
Caption: using all the different tools that we
Caption: have to keep our communication styles
Caption: from just being verbal and using those
Caption: tone expressions as well
Caption: using all of the
Caption: [Music]
Caption: gifs and little icons slack reacts
Caption: whatever it may be to show your emotion
Caption: throughout your communication
Caption: this can help you connect better with
Caption: your friends colleagues and your team
Caption: members and really become an effective
Caption: leader that has that strong
Caption: communication
Caption: for me the next most important
Caption: leadership skill that's underpinned by
Caption: self-awareness is emotional intelligence
Caption: this is sometimes referred to as eq and
Caption: the first thing that is essential for
Caption: any degree of emotional intelligence is
Caption: that self-awareness and understanding of
Caption: ourself
Caption: because emotional intelligence is all
Caption: about being able to recognize our
Caption: emotions to understand the emotions that
Caption: we may be feeling but also how we react
Caption: when we're feeling these emotions and
Caption: the next step is then being able to
Caption: control those emotions in those
Caption: situations
Caption: so there are four components of
Caption: emotional intelligence the first is
Caption: self-awareness the self-awareness is a
Caption: sub-category of emotional intelligence
Caption: but it's really focused on the
Caption: self-awareness of your emotions are you
Caption: feeling happy anxious angry scared
Caption: excited
Caption: what emotion are you feeling
Caption: the next is the self-management
Caption: so that's being able to then control
Caption: those emotions especially in a workplace
Caption: organization if there's something that
Caption: makes you angry you don't want to lash
Caption: out and create a negative situation you
Caption: want to be able to control those
Caption: you also need to be able to adapt when
Caption: things are changing
Caption: and to
Caption: have a positive outlook on things that
Caption: are happening as well
Caption: the next step is that social awareness
Caption: so really being empathetic to those
Caption: around you into the team you can break
Caption: empathy down into three parts the first
Caption: is cognitive which is all about i know
Caption: how you think the next is emotional i
Caption: know how you feel
Caption: and the next is empathetic concern which
Caption: is i care about you
Caption: and great leaders are those that can
Caption: really be empathetic to you in those
Caption: different situations talked about being
Caption: understanding being supportive
Caption: especially in times like through kobed
Caption: when we have you know our kids that
Caption: we're looking after or we have family
Caption: members that might be unwell it's really
Caption: important to have empathetic and
Caption: emotionally intelligent leaders
Caption: and in turn this also is important for
Caption: organizational awareness if something
Caption: negative is happening with your
Caption: organization or your team is
Caption: collectively experiencing some sort of
Caption: emotion being aware of that and then
Caption: also being aware of how you can help
Caption: address it and how you can manage those
Caption: emotions
Caption: in the team by being an influencer by
Caption: being a coach or a mentor and helping
Caption: other people then in turn manage their
Caption: emotions being a diffuser in certain
Caption: situations or helping to uplift your
Caption: team when things
Caption: might not be going so well
Caption: so harnessing these emotions can really
Caption: help us to achieve our goal and it's all
Caption: underpinned by that self-awareness
Caption: so emotional intelligence is super
Caption: important as we said we want people who
Caption: are more empathetic who are more
Caption: understanding and can really relate to
Caption: us in different situations
Caption: we need to make sure that there's some
Caption: sort of work-life balance through our
Caption: people
Caption: and that we can handle change because
Caption: we're in a very rapidly changing type of
Caption: environment especially in tech
Caption: so people with high emotional
Caption: intelligence are naturally curious and
Caption: they're not afraid to ask questions
Caption: they're able to empathize with their
Caption: teammates around them put themselves in
Caption: the shoes of others and really defuse
Caption: any sort of situation when you're
Caption: emotionally intelligent it'll help your
Caption: team members become emotionally
Caption: intelligent too do you come to you when
Caption: they need that support or when they have
Caption: things that they're uncertain about
Caption: because they know that you will be there
Caption: to help them make it through and you'll
Caption: be able to make those really strong
Caption: connections really influence and become
Caption: that great leader
Caption: so how can you increase your emotional
Caption: intelligence
Caption: well one way to do this is just by
Caption: starting to write a list of all the
Caption: different emotions that you know and
Caption: that you know how to feel
Caption: expanding your emotional vocabulary can
Caption: really help you with then in turn
Caption: identifying your emotions
Caption: go out and research different types of
Caption: emotions and see if you're able to
Caption: identify them in yourselves just being
Caption: able to put a name to it can help you to
Caption: be more emotionally
Caption: intelligent then take the time to
Caption: observe how you're reacting in different
Caption: situations especially if things maybe
Caption: didn't go so well maybe there was
Caption: something that made you really
Caption: frustrated and you ended up
Caption: reacting negatively take a step back to
Caption: reflect and think about how you could
Caption: have handled that situation differently
Caption: what was it that triggered that emotion
Caption: and how can you prevent that negative
Caption: reaction in the future
Caption: but also understand that people around
Caption: you and your team members will react
Caption: differently to different situations as
Caption: well
Caption: everyone's definition of hard is
Caption: different
Caption: so even though someone might be
Caption: struggling with it
Caption: try to take a moment to put yourself in
Caption: their issues and understand how they
Caption: might be feeling
Caption: before you send off that angry email
Caption: take a step back and reflect and revisit
Caption: with a new mindset to make sure you're
Caption: approaching the problem positively
Caption: be diplomatic especially in a workplace
Caption: environment and keep things emotion free
Caption: and be able to really ground yourself in
Caption: that self-awareness and keep a steady
Caption: head especially as a leader for your
Caption: team keeping a steady head when things
Caption: might not be going well can help inspire
Caption: your team to keep moving forward as well
Caption: another aspect an important trait to
Caption: being a great leader is something that's
Caption: called self-leadership
Caption: and this is really just the process of
Caption: influencing yourself to achieve your
Caption: goals if you focus on influencing
Caption: yourself it'll naturally leak out to
Caption: those around you and you'll start to be
Caption: an influencer and inspiration a role
Caption: model for others around you
Caption: you don't always have a great leader
Caption: that's going to be giving you all these
Caption: opportunities and pushing you to the
Caption: front so being a leader for yourself is
Caption: very important
Caption: and you can
Caption: influence yourself using a few different
Caption: key strategies the first is through your
Caption: behavior doing that self reflection self
Caption: observation setting some goals for
Caption: yourself and really tracking how you're
Caption: going towards it and reflecting on how
Caption: you may be going
Caption: looking at different keys and little
Caption: idiosyncrasies that you have becoming
Caption: aware of your strengths and weaknesses
Caption: and what you need to work on
Caption: the next is through natural reward
Caption: building pleasure and enjoyable features
Caption: into your work can really help you be
Caption: more driven to continue achieving those
Caption: goals and work harder
Caption: and then it's constructive thought
Caption: patterns evaluating your beliefs and in
Caption: assumptions but with a positive mindset
Caption: practicing that positive self-talk
Caption: especially if you're one who might be
Caption: suffering from something like imposter
Caption: syndrome where you're naturally you know
Caption: holding yourself back practicing that
Caption: positive self talk and reminding you
Caption: yourself that you can do it can help you
Caption: to be a great leader
Caption: so taking together these strategies can
Caption: help you define
Caption: your gain your self-awareness and belief
Caption: that you are constantly working towards
Caption: the goal
Caption: realizing your goal
Caption: recognize rationalize and reflect
Caption: think about how you're acting in
Caption: different ways and really work on
Caption: yourself and that'll naturally flow out
Caption: to the team members around you
Caption: there's also something called
Caption: self-efficacy
Caption: this is an individual's belief in their
Caption: capabilities to execute their behaviors
Caption: so really it's
Caption: the belief in your own ability to
Caption: succeed and this is another thing
Caption: without positive self-talk and the
Caption: self-reflection can help you
Caption: to motivate yourself
Caption: if you are believing in yourself you're
Caption: more likely to take on challenges and be
Caption: better in difficult situations and your
Caption: team members can see that as an
Caption: inspiration and role model see how
Caption: you've handled those negative situations
Caption: see how you're able to continue to keep
Caption: moving forward and believe that yourself
Caption: and your team can reach that goal
Caption: you can develop self-efficacy through
Caption: experience by seeing those people and
Caption: supporting other people around you so
Caption: show the support to your team members as
Caption: well and it'll help them develop their
Caption: self-efficacy
Caption: so working on all these skills can make
Caption: us more confident stronger leaders
Caption: so in turn our benef our followers who
Caption: are following us will then benefit from
Caption: all these different skills that we've
Caption: been working on within ourselves in our
Caption: awareness of ourself
Caption: the followers are very important they're
Caption: the ones who made us leaders in the
Caption: first place
Caption: they look up to us and they really rely
Caption: on us to to help them succeed as well so
Caption: share your knowledge encourage your team
Caption: to reflect any of those things that
Caption: you're learning about yourself share
Caption: with your teams that they can then in
Caption: turn understand and maybe reflect on how
Caption: they act in certain situations as well
Caption: make sure you coach and instead of just
Caption: giving people the answers i had a
Caption: colleague who would always just answer
Caption: any of my questions with a question when
Caption: i asked him for advice
Caption: i would come up to him and say hey
Caption: should i apply for this ryla leadership
Caption: camp and you'd be like well what do you
Caption: think and say okay
Caption: well i think it'd be fine i think it'd
Caption: be a good experience well why do you
Caption: think that and they would just keep
Caption: going on and on to where eventually i
Caption: would then just answer my own question
Caption: but it also encouraged that
Caption: introspection and self reflection which
Caption: made me also understand what was really
Caption: valuable to me and make sure that i was
Caption: creating these goals for myself and
Caption: moving myself forward
Caption: so those there's different techniques
Caption: that you can do to help inspire
Caption: followers but that's one that i always
Caption: enjoy
Caption: and also there's actually a study that
Caption: was published just last year that proved
Caption: that your followers will benefit from
Caption: your leadership
Caption: of your a leader's self-awareness
Caption: so if a leader has strong self-awareness
Caption: this will naturally lead to followers
Caption: being self-leaders because they'll see
Caption: the guidance and inspiration from those
Caption: leaders around them where the leaders
Caption: are you know talking about goal setting
Caption: and these kind of things like that a
Caption: follower will then start to set these
Caption: goals for themselves and drive
Caption: themselves forward
Caption: in turn that will make the leader more
Caption: confident they'll have greater
Caption: self-efficacy and they'll continue to be
Caption: better leaders and reflect that back to
Caption: their followers
Caption: and they also found that this continues
Caption: on so that their followers are then more
Caption: likely to become leaders themselves they
Caption: see the role models and the actions that
Caption: you're doing as a leader and they become
Caption: they're more likely to become a leader
Caption: and they're also more likely to be
Caption: nominated for promotion and more
Caption: successful in their career
Caption: so through working through your
Caption: self-awareness your team and your
Caption: colleagues and people around you will
Caption: become better leaders as well
Caption: and not only will your team become
Caption: better leaders but your organization and
Caption: the company that you're working for will
Caption: benefit from this as well
Caption: enrique research has demonstrated that
Caption: leadership
Caption: behavior is really influenced the
Caption: overall performance of a company
Caption: workers are more trusting of software
Caption: leaders because those leaders are are
Caption: empathetic they're people that we can
Caption: approach their problems we can be open
Caption: about when things are going wrong
Caption: we can talk about you know failures and
Caption: but look at them in a positive light and
Caption: learn from it and move forward
Caption: maya angelou said i've learned that
Caption: people will forget what you said people
Caption: will forget what you did
Caption: but people will never forget how you
Caption: made them feel
Caption: self-aware leaders and teammates can
Caption: really make an impact
Caption: and be
Caption: more engaged in their work and in the
Caption: end produce better results
Caption: so we can build self-awareness first by
Caption: understanding ourselves practicing and
Caption: reevaluating ourselves in the context of
Caption: others using different tools to learn
Caption: about how we approach different
Caption: situations what are our natural
Caption: personality types what are our strengths
Caption: and weaknesses what are some areas that
Caption: we need to work on and when do we need
Caption: to rely on others
Caption: they actually found that
Caption: people
Caption: can build self-awareness by putting
Caption: themselves in situations where their
Caption: focus is naturally drawn inward
Caption: they did this by putting people in front
Caption: of a mirror and recording them and
Caption: recording their actions and then having
Caption: them watch themselves back
Caption: so as much as a lot of us hate watching
Caption: ourselves
Caption: this really helps us become self-aware
Caption: whenever i do a presentation i always go
Caption: back and watch the recording because
Caption: that helps me learn the things that i
Caption: need to work on and things that i can
Caption: improve for next time so put yourself in
Caption: those situations where you're being
Caption: drawn to your yourself and you're seeing
Caption: thinking about or understanding how
Caption: you've acted in different situations to
Caption: help build that self-awareness
Caption: there's also things called
Caption: self-awareness triggers which are
Caption: usually some big events that happen in
Caption: our life that really make us reflect and
Caption: understand a bit of ourselves on a
Caption: deeper level
Caption: but these are only really beneficial to
Caption: helping our self-awareness if we take
Caption: that time to reflect to think about how
Caption: did we react in that situation how did
Caption: we handle that how could what could we
Caption: have done differently change those
Caption: questions
Caption: from why to what take those tests talk
Caption: to the people around you get that
Caption: feedback from your teammates as well to
Caption: help build that external self-awareness
Caption: and understand how you are perceived by
Caption: others and those around you
Caption: do you you need to work more on your
Caption: mindfulness do you need to build up that
Caption: emotional intelligence do you need to
Caption: sort of control your emotions different
Caption: situations what are you really good at
Caption: maybe how do you need to alter your
Caption: communication for certain team members
Caption: take a step back slow down your emotions
Caption: boil and practice that self-regulation
Caption: so in summary we learned about
Caption: leadership and that anyone can be a
Caption: leader we can all build up our
Caption: self-awareness and that can drive us to
Caption: become better leaders and in turn our
Caption: followers and our teammates those people
Caption: around us are more likely to become
Caption: leaders as well
Caption: we learned how self-awareness can be
Caption: negative if we don't think about it in
Caption: the right aspect
Caption: so we need and we don't focus on both
Caption: the internal and external so we need to
Caption: to balance those two sides and practice
Caption: that positive self-talk change our
Caption: questions from why to what and look at
Caption: how we can learn and move forward
Caption: we heard how self-awareness can be
Caption: beneficial to ourselves
Caption: our team and our organization
Caption: so through self-awareness you can be a
Caption: great leader
Caption: and i'll leave you with his quote
Caption: at the center of your being you have the
Caption: answer
Caption: you know who you are and you know what
Caption: you want
Caption: so thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: and if you scan the qr code on the
Caption: screen or go to the bitly link um you
Caption: can get access to all of my resources
Caption: that are used in the talk today as well
Caption: as my slides and everything as well
Caption: hello great talk melissa
Caption: um so you mentioned failures and looking
Caption: at them in a positive light do you have
Caption: any recent examples of situations you've
Caption: done that
Caption: so looking at things in a positive light
Caption: yeah um
Caption: yeah well so for example you know i so
Caption: living in melbourne um in the pandemic
Caption: we had you know really intense lockdowns
Caption: that were
Caption: you know quite difficult to to work with
Caption: um and so there was a lot of negative
Caption: emotions and negative things happening
Caption: with um the lockdowns and it was a
Caption: struggle to to manage
Caption: during that scenario but on i tried to
Caption: reflect on it in a positive light on the
Caption: things that i was able to achieve over
Caption: that time so
Caption: even though you know it was a
Caption: really difficult time
Caption: in my life i was able to focus on things
Caption: like practicing public speaking and
Caption: doing virtual talks and
Caption: learning more about myself and doing
Caption: more of that self-reflection and
Caption: everything as well so instead of
Caption: focusing on sort of the negative things
Caption: of being stuck in your house not being
Caption: able to see people i focused on the
Caption: things that i was able to achieve
Caption: despite um you know being in a situation
Caption: even if it wasn't every day that i was
Caption: able to you know be super productive
Caption: there's definitely a lot of days that
Caption: were spent you know just sitting on the
Caption: couch being a bit miserable um focusing
Caption: on the days that were positive where i
Caption: was able to achieve something despite
Caption: the situation
Caption: i
Caption: you told about one of your colleagues or
Caption: one of your
Caption: maybe one of your colleagues where
Caption: uh your colleague was
Caption: kind of
Caption: more dominating in in her personality so
Caption: how did you get get about it get around
Caption: it because you did tell that you did
Caption: some certain strategies around it but in
Caption: that situation what kind of strategies
Caption: did you use because that was something
Caption: which didn't you didn't elaborate on it
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah so the the colleague was a bit more
Caption: dominating and indirect whereas i'm
Caption: naturally um a bit more i i guess um
Caption: yeah sort of less direct um in my
Caption: approach to things um
Caption: so i well part of it was when i was
Caption: communicating with her i made sure that
Caption: i i was very direct and straight to the
Caption: point um so that she would understand
Caption: the message that i was getting across
Caption: and when it came to her communications
Caption: with me i would often
Caption: especially if it was something oversight
Caption: email or would not do that strategy of
Caption: instead of doing my initial reaction
Caption: which was often take plot taken aback
Caption: because
Caption: because it was often quite forceful what
Caption: she was saying i would just pause and
Caption: think about it for a second and try to
Caption: think about the message that she
Caption: probably was actually trying to convey
Caption: really giving her the benefit of the
Caption: doubt that she probably wasn't
Caption: trying to be mean or aggressive she was
Caption: just trying to be direct in her message
Caption: and get the information across so it's
Caption: part of putting yourself in the other
Caption: person's shoes
Caption: and
Caption: taking a step back and then also trying
Caption: to even replicate their ways of
Caption: communicating with their actions when
Caption: you're working with them so that they're
Caption: more receptive
Caption: to the things that you're describing
Caption: and also she
Caption: took the test as well so she was also
Caption: more than aware of my personality and my
Caption: traits
Caption: which helped the way she was
Caption: working with me
Caption: it made it so that she was less direct
Caption: because she realized that it wasn't
Caption: really the the way that i like to
Caption: communicate or work myself
Caption: um thank you my name's cecily that was
Caption: an amazing presentation um as a super
Caption: self-aware perfect leader um how do i
Caption: help um
Caption: other leaders who are trying to get me
Caption: to follow but they're not particularly
Caption: self-aware is there any way to inspire
Caption: up when
Caption: you can't be like hey do a personality
Caption: test
Caption: yeah um well feedback is is very very
Caption: powerful tool um you know a lot of
Caption: people yeah they might just not be aware
Caption: of what they're doing that you know they
Caption: might not be aware that what they're
Caption: saying is you know putting people in a
Caption: bad mood or that it's you know really
Caption: not helping the team so just giving that
Caption: feedback to them
Caption: and
Caption: having it be like an open conversation
Caption: of you know saying
Caption: um in in this situation this is you know
Caption: the the outcomes of what happens
Caption: how do you think about that and giving
Caption: them the opportunity to reflect
Caption: themselves
Caption: so saying you know how how do you think
Caption: the team reacted in that situation
Caption: and letting them you know have the space
Caption: through your questions like my colleague
Caption: who is always saying why
Caption: why do you want to do that um getting
Caption: them almost forcing them to reflect as
Caption: well
Caption: okay i think that's all we have time for
Caption: thank you so much melissa
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: first
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: let's go
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are going to love it i got
Caption: a real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's stephen
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years
Caption: people have trusted us to turn ambitious
Caption: projects into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my goal sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the barrack completely makes sense as
Caption: for the ping no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of um sparks and enjoy and so yeah
Caption: so being there it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than
Caption: yesterday that's always been me so i'm
Caption: better than yesterday and i'll be better
Caption: tomorrow i also get a lot of training
Caption: opportunities and planning because
Caption: there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities you
Caption: know whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made sure that ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: night
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: let's go
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are gonna love it i
Caption: got a real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's stephen
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: whoops what mark where are you mark open
Caption: you turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshini i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the barrack completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of um sparks and enjoy and so yeah
Caption: so being better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your carrier you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: do
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: let's go
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we needed asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: like
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my core sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the very completely makes sense as
Caption: for the ping no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: whatever you need to progress in your
Caption: carrier you have got everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: hi
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our puppies
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: let's go
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's
Caption: steven what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: do
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: friends i'm scott hanselman and i was
Caption: told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: business
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years
Caption: people have trusted us to turn ambitious
Caption: projects into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they call
Caption: me gesture because i always have a smile
Caption: on my face whatever situation i'm in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my core sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the very completely makes sense as
Caption: for the ping no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and and joy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me
Caption: so i'm better than yesterday and i'll be
Caption: better tomorrow i also get a lot of
Caption: training opportunities and planning
Caption: because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: joined planet like when you want to
Caption: learn something google first right and
Caption: then when you google something you
Caption: always have to pay for something and
Caption: that's not that's not what i want to do
Caption: so it's really it's really good that
Caption: planet offers these free courses for me
Caption: and i don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top note
Caption: of testing is
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to
Caption: want to learn and get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boosts your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hi
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our puzzles
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: woops mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck
Caption: my dream come true i've always wanted to
Caption: join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: let's go
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little
Caption: problem as you know our motto is you
Caption: need a professional bodyguard delivered
Caption: to your door in less than half an hour
Caption: you've got it buddy but without an app
Caption: ain't no bodyguard getting delivered
Caption: nowhere so where are we with that uh the
Caption: app is almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: like
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering it
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my core sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the direct completely makes sense as
Caption: for the ping no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me
Caption: so i'm better than yesterday and i'll be
Caption: better tomorrow i also get a lot of
Caption: training opportunities and planning
Caption: because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: and the title of her talk is github
Caption: pilot using ai to help you learn code
Caption: and build
Caption: it's a bit about michelle michelle is a
Caption: highly motivated curious and
Caption: compassionate leader with a keen
Caption: interest in driving entrepreneurial
Caption: culture and pioneering melbourne's s e
Caption: sports industry
Caption: she has
Caption: founded several tech companies and as a
Caption: result sits at the forefront of this
Caption: city's science tech esports and startup
Caption: scenes
Caption: when not working at github michelle
Caption: keeps herself busy as a streamer a
Caption: journalist a quidditch player and a
Caption: conference attendee and is always
Caption: looking to work on something exciting
Caption: thanks michelle
Caption: thank you thank you everyone so yeah my
Caption: talk's titled github co-pilot lots of
Caption: you know or i've heard about copilot so
Caption: i know you're all here to actually
Caption: hear about co-pilot and not actually to
Caption: listen to me talk
Caption: but yeah as i said my name is michelle
Caption: or mish feel freddie come on mish
Caption: there's all my social media
Caption: feel free to follow me i know the
Caption: speaker bingo is still going so if you
Caption: take some photos of me please tweet them
Caption: i do have a couple of pair of github
Caption: socks to give away as well to some of my
Caption: favorite tweets so tweak them and i'll
Caption: reply to you if you win
Caption: so i'm a developer advocate at github
Caption: i've come over from melbourne and yeah
Caption: really exciting to be here and to talk
Caption: to you all about co-pilot
Caption: so today's talk we're going to be
Caption: covering a couple of little things
Caption: before we actually go into the co-pilot
Caption: side of stuff so talk about the idea of
Caption: um ai artificial intelligence what we're
Caption: doing in the space
Caption: obviously co-pilot is an ai we're going
Caption: to get to that in a bit
Caption: talk a little bit about the applications
Caption: of ai and how it's relevant today
Caption: then we're obviously going to talk about
Caption: co-pilot
Caption: and do a little bit of a demo i'm going
Caption: to finish off talking about this idea
Caption: and this concept of ownership
Caption: so first up what is ai
Caption: now a lot of people here have heard
Caption: about ai it's a relatively
Caption: you know
Caption: big part of computing and it's becoming
Caption: bigger and bigger as becoming smarter
Caption: and smarter as the name suggests
Caption: now if you google images of ai you'll
Caption: probably see this kind of stuff this you
Caption: know
Caption: digital interface you know that the
Caption: whole iron man jarvis type stuff is is
Caption: what we kind of see if we start googling
Caption: but what does artificial intelligence
Caption: mean what is the definition of
Caption: artificial intelligence
Caption: now ibm has defined it as this
Caption: which is artificial intelligence
Caption: leverages computers and machines
Caption: to mimic the problem-solving
Caption: capabilities and decision-making of
Caption: people
Caption: so this definition has been
Caption: refined over the years originally ai um
Caption: came out of like the touring project
Caption: and then it's kind of moved into more
Caption: about okay well now it's um you know
Caption: machine learning we're all about
Caption: training models but now we're getting
Caption: into this more stage of artificial
Caption: intelligence and back in the day when i
Caption: first started doing um startups one of
Caption: my first startups was actually an ai
Caption: company you see a lot of ai startups and
Caption: you get oh yeah we're doing artificial
Caption: intelligence you're like sweet what are
Caption: you doing they're like this this and
Caption: this you're like
Caption: yeah that's not ai that's actually
Caption: machine learning so machine learning
Caption: itself is training the model and
Caption: teaching the things
Caption: ai is now into that more decision making
Caption: process
Caption: what have i learnt
Caption: and what can i then use to solve this
Caption: problem
Caption: so that's where the difference is in ai
Caption: and machine learning
Caption: now i think movies are a really really
Caption: good way um to think about the concepts
Caption: of
Caption: this kind of like future tech
Caption: now when we used to talk about you know
Caption: what's future technology going to look
Caption: like oh look at movies like back to the
Caption: future and minority portal i mean i
Caption: wonder when that's going to come in and
Caption: literally the other day i was having a
Caption: conversation with my housemate and he's
Caption: like you know with all this stuff you're
Caption: doing really not that far away from java
Caption: so i might we're actually already here
Caption: um this whole idea of java is this
Caption: machine not the physical part not the
Caption: ultron side of it but the original iron
Caption: man side of it um you know the 19
Caption: whatever movie it was now in the back in
Caption: the 90s
Caption: this whole idea of training this system
Caption: with lots of data points and it can now
Caption: tell us what to do
Caption: it can give us information from all this
Caption: understanding and all this stuff that
Caption: we've trained it on
Caption: for example everyone saying this hey
Caption: siri
Caption: now when hey siri and google and alexa
Caption: when they started
Caption: they were kind of like glorified search
Caption: engines
Caption: hey siri how long is the great wall of
Caption: china who's who's old enough to remember
Caption: that nbn ad or the internet ad hey dad
Caption: why did they build a white great wall of
Caption: china oh yeah to keep rabbits out
Caption: and the whole thing was like give your
Caption: kids the right answer
Caption: so
Caption: siri when it started was this glorified
Caption: search engine now it's a bit more
Caption: hey you know people always say oh you
Caption: know your phone's listening into you
Caption: well yeah it is because it's trying to
Caption: understand and learn so now it doesn't
Caption: just give you information that you need
Caption: to know it says oh i've also noticed
Caption: that um you played golf the other day
Caption: do you need some more golf balls because
Caption: you might have lost a few
Caption: so another one is google nest now we see
Caption: this idea of um the connected home the
Caption: connected devices google nest now uses
Caption: artificial intelligence to you in their
Caption: cameras to see if there's intruders in
Caption: your house which is i think kind of cool
Caption: so it's built up an image recognition of
Caption: who you are and it's now learnt who you
Caption: are as a person it can now detect other
Caption: people in the house and then send you a
Caption: thing saying hey we think someone else
Caption: is in your house based on the movement
Caption: patterns of you and this other person
Caption: that we don't recognize we think there's
Caption: someone in your house
Caption: so there comes some some of the
Caption: applications there
Caption: who drives a car here pretty much
Caption: everyone
Caption: now everyone's like when self-driving
Caption: cars coming out i'm like well ai and
Caption: machine learning has been in cars for a
Caption: while this idea of not just power assist
Caption: but now i've got driver assist you know
Caption: traction controls off you know stay in
Caption: the lanes get off the road or stay on
Caption: the road rather
Caption: this idea of driver assist right
Caption: and people like oh yes i can start
Caption: seeing it in our daily lives what about
Caption: technology
Caption: i came across this one the other day
Caption: called um what was it called
Caption: um i can't remember the name it hasn't
Caption: put it up here but there's a there's a
Caption: machine learning an ai algorithm it's in
Caption: my
Caption: resource at the end it actually writes
Caption: articles for you
Caption: so you don't even need to be a
Caption: journalist anymore and outside my job at
Caption: github i'm a journalist and i'm like oh
Caption: geez
Caption: um
Caption: the computers are coming for my job
Caption: but yeah they can they can write
Caption: articles
Caption: there's a really really contentious
Caption: thing that popped up the other day a lot
Caption: of people probably seen it
Caption: this idea of artwork there's a famous us
Caption: art prize that went out and it ended up
Caption: going to a person who uses um used
Caption: computer generated imagery to create the
Caption: artwork now what i think is really cool
Caption: about the artwork side of things and
Caption: we're going to get to it in a little bit
Caption: is the more specific
Caption: you give
Caption: the more parameters that you give the
Caption: the engine the better artwork you're
Caption: going to make and i made that one on mid
Caption: journey just the other day
Caption: and so if you type in some fun things
Caption: you might get something back to you like
Caption: oh that's a bit weird it's not the
Caption: computer or the system not um like
Caption: giving you something something oh it's a
Caption: little bit dumb isn't it might well no
Caption: you just haven't told it what you want
Caption: now we're starting to see it in
Caption: programming
Caption: we're starting to see this idea of not
Caption: just glorified search engines coming in
Caption: to help you but programs that are coming
Caption: in to help code
Caption: and if you have a look again it's going
Caption: to be um there's a link at the end of a
Caption: bunch of resources
Caption: there's the top 10
Caption: ai pair program or ai
Caption: systems plugins that you can use for vs
Caption: code
Caption: one of them is ali ai which helps you
Caption: understand what you've written
Caption: yeah because because you need you need
Caption: to know that as a developer what kind of
Caption: code have i written here i actually was
Caption: talking to someone the other day of
Caption: dinner and they're like yeah sometimes
Caption: you just don't know what you're right
Caption: i'm like that's where an ai pair program
Caption: would help
Caption: now on that list they obviously have
Caption: github copilot as one of the top
Caption: ai extensions that you can use in vs
Caption: code
Caption: so what is github copilot
Caption: github copilot is your ai pair
Caption: programmer
Caption: this is there to help you
Caption: build write and understand your code
Caption: better
Caption: like the other extensions in vs code
Caption: it's built right into your editor
Caption: and you can use it to help you write
Caption: code
Caption: now if we have a look at it here
Caption: this is
Caption: a little quick example of it
Caption: it's built on
Caption: the ai open codecs
Caption: some of my slides are actually back to
Caption: front here but it's built on the ai
Caption: codex i should have used ai and copilot
Caption: to write my slide deck
Caption: but yeah it's built on ai codecs it's
Caption: trained on billions of lines of code you
Caption: can see here it's suggesting this whole
Caption: function
Caption: but unlike some of its um predecessors
Caption: or pre-existing
Caption: ai features and ai functionality
Caption: it's not just auto complete
Caption: it is not just saying
Caption: looking at going oh hang on i think i
Caption: know what you're gonna write so let me
Caption: auto complete that for you we're having
Caption: this conversation over dinner the other
Caption: night and i was like oh isn't that the
Caption: whole idea of like reducing the amount
Caption: of keystrokes that you make and i was
Caption: like well not really
Caption: because you can either just learn a type
Caption: faster or you can use shortcuts like the
Caption: whole idea isn't just reducing the
Caption: amount of keystrokes it should be about
Caption: being better programmers and actually
Caption: writing better code
Caption: so that's what copilot does
Caption: and it doesn't just provide you with
Caption: snippets of code doesn't just say oh you
Caption: know you want to write this thing here's
Caption: a snippet of code and you know i'm going
Caption: to give you the same snippet of code and
Caption: give you the same snippety code view the
Caption: same snippety code no it doesn't do that
Caption: it actually uses
Caption: what you've currently got in your file
Caption: and what it knows about the language
Caption: you're writing
Caption: and uses that context when i'm saying
Caption: before about if the more parameters that
Caption: you give it uses the context of what
Caption: you're trying to do
Caption: to actually synthesize code that's
Caption: specific for you so if we all go use
Caption: co-pilot right now we're all going to
Caption: get very very different responses when
Caption: we start using it which i think is
Caption: really cool
Caption: one of the other ways it differs from
Caption: some of its pre-existing models
Caption: is just the sheer scale of copilot
Caption: when we work with
Caption: machine learning
Caption: and we're using machine learning to
Caption: train artificial intelligence models
Caption: one of the things that we need is lots
Caption: and lots of data points
Caption: have you heard of like the phrase
Caption: dodgy data in dodgy data out
Caption: so what we've done is we haven't just
Caption: put dodgy data into it we've used data
Caption: we've used really good quality data to
Caption: train the model but we've also used
Caption: literally billions and billions of data
Caption: points
Caption: lots and lots of code to train this
Caption: model
Caption: so it is an ai pair programmer you can
Caption: sit down and code with
Caption: and again our same conversation of
Caption: having my housemate who isn't actually
Caption: in technology he's like oh it's kind of
Caption: like
Caption: from why you're describing it's kind of
Caption: like you sitting there
Caption: writing code and it's like having a
Caption: senior developer
Caption: working next year and i was like well
Caption: yeah but it's like having like 83
Caption: million developers senior developers
Caption: working next year not that everyone
Caption: using github as a senior developer but
Caption: you're basically using the collective
Caption: knowledge of the internet
Caption: to then help you write code which i
Caption: think is really cool i mean that's one
Caption: of the coolest things about us being
Caption: able to sit down and um you know where
Caption: we've come now in history right we're
Caption: able to use the collective knowledge of
Caption: everyone else who came before us so why
Caption: can't we use that every single day while
Caption: we code
Caption: and one of the things i really like
Caption: about the co-pilot too is
Caption: it's not really limited to any
Caption: particular person
Caption: right you know david did a fantastic
Caption: talk before on like code spaces and
Caption: actions and all those kind of cool stuff
Caption: like yeah that's so cool you know but
Caption: some of it when you start getting it
Caption: deep i'm like oh it's kind of beyond my
Caption: knowledge
Caption: but with co-pilot pretty much every
Caption: single person can use it whether you're
Caption: a developer that's just starting out or
Caption: you're a senior developer working on
Caption: facebook or instagram or whatever you're
Caption: doing and that's what i really like
Caption: about it
Caption: so here's a little snippet from our
Caption: website so you can see it works in
Caption: multiple languages as well
Caption: so we have lots of different languages
Caption: you can use copilot with
Caption: and you can see a little bit in a demo
Caption: about the different types of ways you
Caption: can use those languages
Caption: and what i really like about too is it
Caption: doesn't just provide you with code that
Caption: it thinks you need it provides you with
Caption: really really meaningful code based on
Caption: the context that you've got
Caption: all right let's get into a demo there's
Caption: a couple of spoilers in there so i was
Caption: like let's not talk about those now
Caption: let's talk about the demo
Caption: right so in this demo
Caption: this is pre-recorded but it's mine i did
Caption: this myself like literally two days ago
Caption: one of the reasons i did it pre-recorded
Caption: is we don't have a lot of time we
Caption: literally have like 20 minutes the
Caption: second reason is because copilot learns
Caption: it means that when i finish writing the
Caption: code already knows i'm going to write
Caption: what i want so i'm going to show you in
Caption: a minute but basically if you haven't
Caption: used github co-pilot before
Caption: you need to go to
Caption: the vs code extension
Caption: marketplace
Caption: you can grab copilot
Caption: install it
Caption: you log into github
Caption: like use your credentials to log in
Caption: and then you allow it and then you can
Caption: start using copilot
Caption: so you can see down the bottom there
Caption: that little co-pile icon there
Caption: so when we're using it this is an
Caption: example
Caption: that i wrote the other day
Caption: i was on twilio quest trying to do one
Caption: of their coding challenges and i got a
Caption: little bit stuck and i was like hahaha i
Caption: can use copilot
Caption: and i was doing this live on a twitch
Caption: stream as well so what i'm providing up
Caption: there is um basically the um the problem
Caption: that it was asking me to solve and
Caption: interestingly enough even though i wrote
Caption: that out as a comment to start off with
Caption: it tried to give me a function so what
Caption: the problem there is basically reverse
Caption: the sentence
Caption: all the letters need to be
Caption: non-capitalized unless it's the name of
Caption: something the first letter of the word
Caption: of the reverse sentence needs to be
Caption: capitalized and the punctuation needs to
Caption: go at the end so obviously when i wrote
Caption: oh we need to reverse the sentence just
Caption: give me one function it says reverse a
Caption: sentence i was like okay co-pilot needs
Caption: more context here
Caption: so what i'm writing out and this is what
Caption: i did on my stream i was like all right
Caption: what are the steps that i need to go
Caption: through to solve this problem let's
Caption: write them out in plain english each
Caption: step that i need to do
Caption: so i'm here i'm going okay first let's
Caption: actually make the first letter of the
Caption: sentence lower case it was not an i i
Caption: had a bunch of sentences and i was like
Caption: let's not not worry about like names of
Caption: places let's just start a little bit
Caption: basic with an iron so i was like okay
Caption: um okay co-pilot let's see what you can
Caption: give me and i was like all right let's
Caption: um change a couple little parameters
Caption: here just to make it a little bit easier
Caption: to understand
Caption: but
Caption: by providing copilot with the context
Caption: and the way that i want to solve this
Caption: problem it's able to help me better than
Caption: the original um snippet of code that it
Caption: gave me which is reverse the sentence
Caption: i'm like well that's great if i just
Caption: want to reverse the sentence i already
Caption: knew how to do that
Caption: um so let's go through these ones so i
Caption: was like right next we want to split the
Caption: sentence into an array of words because
Caption: we actually want to reverse this
Caption: sentence
Caption: so it's like all right that's there and
Caption: i'm like oh sweet that's pretty good too
Caption: and i'm sitting there going tab tab tab
Caption: well i'm live streaming this thing
Caption: which is pretty cool i was like i don't
Caption: have to do anything here yeah co-pilot
Caption: really is going to take my job provides
Caption: these all the punctuation marks there
Caption: but i was like oh no i want to make sure
Caption: that um this the words yeah there you go
Caption: it's pretty pretty cool hey
Caption: um so yeah i was like all right now
Caption: let's take out the punctuation marks
Caption: from the sentence and what i want to do
Caption: is i want to store them still so i can
Caption: add them back in later which is why i'm
Caption: um adding the array there i was like
Caption: right now we're going to remove them so
Caption: all right there it is let's replace the
Caption: punctuation marks there with um with
Caption: nothing at the end um so i was like oh
Caption: i'm going to call it a sentence because
Caption: that's going to be easy and then
Caption: obviously last thing we want to do is we
Caption: want to um
Caption: split no obviously we've done this now
Caption: let's split the sentence reverse the
Caption: sentence and come on
Caption: i'm typing really slow on it um let's
Caption: reverse the sentence join it back
Caption: together again and add the punctuation
Caption: marks at the end i was like sweet um
Caption: what are you gonna give me
Caption: okay that's uh pretty good co-pilot
Caption: um so let's let's name that there and i
Caption: was like sweet
Caption: i basically have
Caption: most of my stuff there thanks to
Caption: co-pilot um changed a couple little
Caption: parameters as you can see i had a help
Caption: from a
Caption: developer who's a lot more senior than
Caption: me um doing this on stream
Caption: but yeah this was like really cool that
Caption: co-pilot was able to do this now i was
Caption: like finally yeah we need to add the
Caption: punctuation marks back into the sentence
Caption: and we need to actually join it back
Caption: together so you can see here it's trying
Caption: to predict what i'm asked like what it
Caption: wants to do but i'm like providing with
Caption: a little bit more context each time we
Caption: can see that bang
Caption: it's provided that was me i was like
Caption: that's really cool
Caption: again let's double check that with some
Caption: code that a senior developer gave you
Caption: and i was like well that's exactly what
Caption: he wrote
Caption: basically
Caption: i think co-pilot's coming for your job
Caption: mate um no just kidding but basically
Caption: it's really awesome it's able to provide
Caption: you with a lot of context and i'm gonna
Caption: give you a couple of quotes here these
Caption: are straight off our website
Caption: um but yeah like people are just
Caption: absolutely loving um what co-pilot does
Caption: so it is
Caption: pretty awesome and it's like actually
Caption: mind-blowing um the technology it does
Caption: now as i was saying before one of the
Caption: reasons why i didn't want to do this
Caption: live
Caption: is because when you are writing copilot
Caption: and you can see there we went through
Caption: all the stuff
Caption: co-pilot's learning
Caption: it's learning what you want it to do and
Caption: for you so i was like okay what happens
Caption: if i have done this live
Caption: something like this probably would have
Caption: happened so open up a brand new file
Caption: copy and paste that same bit in there
Caption: and copart goes oh yeah i think i know
Caption: what you're trying to do um i reckon
Caption: you're trying to reverse a sentence and
Caption: bang
Caption: the whole thing i was like
Caption: that's what would have happened if we
Caption: hadn't done this live and you wouldn't
Caption: have got that cool like that you know
Caption: the suspense of each part you know
Caption: breaking down the uh the problem and
Caption: understanding how to actually do that so
Caption: um thanks for that one co-file that was
Caption: really cool
Caption: now people really like this and again my
Caption: the time i talk isn't just using
Caption: co-pilot to code it's using co-pilots
Caption: actually understand and learn with your
Caption: code not just it learn right
Caption: so you've launched these new things
Caption: shortly after co-pilot called github
Caption: co-pilot labs you get another extension
Caption: so you go to the vs marketplace install
Caption: that in there and then you'll see this
Caption: little pop-up on the side of your vs
Caption: code called co-pilot labs now what i
Caption: like about co-pilot labs is it actually
Caption: helps you again the same function here
Caption: it actually helps you especially if
Caption: you're starting learning
Caption: actually helps to explain and understand
Caption: your code now again someone was you know
Caption: you're kind of laughing at me before you
Caption: wrote the code though don't you
Caption: understand it not always what happens if
Caption: i opened up this in a code space or
Caption: forked
Caption:  um some code from someone else or
Caption: cloned a repo what i can do now is i can
Caption: now highlight parts of code and get
Caption: co-pilot to actually explain what's
Caption: going on here
Caption: so copa again if i click um
Caption: if i keep clicking ask it'll try and
Caption: explain it in a different way kind of
Caption: like a teacher it's like i didn't quite
Caption: understand it first time i will try
Caption: again
Caption: and it gives you a bunch of different
Caption: options to actually explain your code so
Caption: you can explain it in plain english um
Caption: yes this is a function design or you
Caption: know to
Caption: see if the first letter of the character
Caption: in the sentence is actually an i if not
Caption: then it'll change it you can actually
Caption: get it to explain it in um more in-depth
Caption: english or so like slightly longer and
Caption: then you can also get it to explain it
Caption: to you in terms of like the syntax what
Caption: parts of the function being called
Caption: and then finally you can actually get it
Caption: to give you
Caption: an example what would actually happen
Caption: talked about this last night dinner as
Caption: well the idea of actually translating
Caption: your code this is still something we're
Caption: working on so it's not perfect but you
Caption: can actually translate your code into
Caption: other languages so if you're a python
Caption: developer and just wanting to learn um
Caption: something else like ruby php whatever
Caption: you can now get it to
Caption: try and help you translate your code now
Caption: obviously it's not perfect you can see a
Caption: couple of you're snickering there in the
Caption: corner it's not perfect it's not um it's
Caption: not great we're getting there um but
Caption: yeah have a look at that um
Caption: so
Caption: somebody asked me the other day i'm
Caption: nearly wrapping up but what happens if i
Caption: actually don't want copilot to use the
Caption: stuff that i've got to learn
Caption: what if also it doesn't does co-pilot
Caption: ever actually give us the same
Caption: um
Caption: piece of code
Caption: because it's still a relatively new
Caption: model and you know what we're still
Caption: doing we're still learning
Caption: you can actually
Caption: get copilot to filter out some of the
Caption: things that it can tell you
Caption: so in most cases the code that copart
Caption: gives you is specific to you it's been
Caption: synthesized just for you
Caption: in less than one percent of the cases
Caption: however you might get code that is
Caption: similar to something that is already in
Caption: an open source repository so you can
Caption: turn off the filter in your co-pilot
Caption: settings on github and say actually
Caption: block these suggestions so if there's a
Caption: snippet of code that's even you know 100
Caption: characters i can't remember exactly what
Caption: it is but about 100 characters similar
Caption: to another piece of code that's on the
Caption: internet don't show it to me
Caption: then under that you also saw there was
Caption: that
Caption: option to say do not use my code
Caption: for improving github's products so your
Caption: code won't be used
Caption: if you like copilot head over to the
Caption: co-pilot website copilot.kdob.com
Caption: and try it out
Caption: it is free for 60 days for anyone to try
Caption: otherwise i think it says 120 dollars
Caption: for the year something like that
Caption: 10 a month
Caption: and then
Caption: and 100 for a year so you get you know
Caption: two months free if you sign up for the
Caption: whole year
Caption: teachers i just found out if you're a
Caption: teacher you now get co-part for free as
Caption: part of the um campus program the github
Caption: global campus program it's a teacher you
Caption: get it for free
Caption: and obviously open source developers um
Caption: you get that um for free as well working
Caption: on a big open source project now finally
Caption: i know where um at time but finally i
Caption: really want to touch on this point of
Caption: ownership because it comes up all the
Caption: time
Caption: um
Caption: regardless of whether it's the articles
Caption: that we're talking about before the
Caption: artwork um here with program people like
Caption: what happens with you know ai like
Caption: ownership who owns the thing do i own it
Caption: because i you know built the artwork
Caption: does the program own it because they're
Caption: the ones who built the ai does the open
Caption: ai own it
Caption: most of the time we've come to the
Caption: conclusion that nearly all these things
Caption: they they allow the people who actually
Caption: create it to have the ownership and it's
Caption: exactly the same with co-pilot so the
Caption: code that you write with co-pilot is
Caption: your code nobody else owns it we don't
Caption: own it you own it someone to finish on
Caption: that
Caption: finally again there's a gist up there
Caption: for all the resources links to
Caption: everything um
Caption: that i spoke about
Caption: if you do have questions because
Caption: obviously you don't have time for
Caption: questions and i never included time for
Caption: questions you can tweet me on all the
Caption: social media platforms known to man or
Caption: come chat to us at the booth because i
Caption: have couple pairs of socks giveaway
Caption: thank you so much for listening to me
Caption: co-pilot in 20 minutes
Caption: thank you so much
Caption: thank you so much mish all right so we
Caption: are slightly over time afternoon tea is
Caption: just out there back in the theater at
Caption: 405 for the lock note thanks so much
Caption: everybody
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: like
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: true do you want
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we needed asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: like
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very permanent accent
Caption: so the very completely makes sense
Caption: as for the ping no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with a hello kitty
Caption: riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in
Caption: the it industry in general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: from
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: like
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: whoops what mark where are you mark open
Caption: you turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott handsome
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: let's go
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little
Caption: problem as you know our motto is you
Caption: need a professional bodyguard delivered
Caption: to your door in less than half an hour
Caption: you've got it buddy but without an app
Caption: ain't no bodyguard getting delivered
Caption: nowhere so where are we with that uh the
Caption: app is almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: night
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign um
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: business
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join
Caption: someone's ooh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the direct completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top line
Caption: of testing is um it's awesome it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top run is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality
Caption: everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: first
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott handsome
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their i.t needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: let's go
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: grown from a small technology provider
Caption: founded by two young brothers to a
Caption: fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge
Caption: maths nerd uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret uh as you can tell by the
Caption: accent i am french very very prominent
Caption: accent
Caption: so the direct completely makes sense as
Caption: for the ping no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly
Caption: but i think it brings a little bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top line
Caption: of testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better um i think that's really
Caption: important and i think it's going to be a
Caption: driving factor going forward in in the
Caption: it industry in general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: whatever you need to progress in your
Caption: career you have got everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: god
Caption: first
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: do
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our puzzles
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their i.t needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: hey
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: business
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: let's go
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are gonna love it i
Caption: got a real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: business
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that when they see when they see
Caption: the cereal box they say okay that's
Caption: carol
Caption: hi i'm josh joshini i'm a test engineer
Caption: they call me gesture because i always
Caption: have a smile on my face whatever
Caption: situation i'm in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the direct completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say i'm not
Caption: the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills
Caption: having new challenges and taking them
Caption: and i think it's very inspiring we
Caption: better build better personally i always
Caption: try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: first
Caption: hi
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: businesses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: let's go
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we needed asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero up what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join
Caption: someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm josh nate i'm a test engineer
Caption: they call me gesture because i always
Caption: have a smile on my face whatever
Caption: situation i'm in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the direct completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward
Caption: in in the it industry in general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: whatever you need to progress in your
Caption: career you have got everything in here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: hi
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our puppies
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's ooh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: let's go
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up
Caption: steven we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: do
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye